et on a les caméras les joueurs en plus
on a les joueurs on a toi en à moi et on
va essayer de voir le jeu et c'est de
voir le chat switch heel et petit à
petit on va être bon
ok mauvaise blessure chez ce col du cou
pour voir les trucs maintenant à
partager temps donc
mais possible que ce soit plus simple
comme ça ok sur twitter sa marque va les
vérifier
pour un quatuor en vidéo dans le team à
rognan dans les pattes et team aerial
moi je sui team sui team dépôt on est
que pendant 7 à voir suis à 100 aïe aïe
aïe j'ai pas réussi à ouvrir le chat je
suis entré au ps
le chat moi je suis sur l'autre choc moi
je peux encore le fond c'est quoi le
petit bruit cela derrière toi là le
petit voilà ce sont plus loire mais
c'est pas non mais c'est à dire les
rebelles se sont dit on sait pas c'est
pas grave c'est pas grave battus par
exemple je m'en veux juste regarder ce
qui se passe
j'arrive en dessous nous allons arrêter
je suis je menace d'y aller je me trompe
donc je raisonne je vais réaliser mais
et je suis orient c'est ça ouais j'suis
jumelles ah ben ça y est c'est parti je
vais dire aurions je te suis
allez c'est pas c'est parti je vais
suivre à rognan ici plus tôt donc c'est
parti voici une anglaise il a ajouté
quatre points niveau car il commence lui
par le 311 par les 960 je ne comprends
rien non mais je ne crois enfin de
trouver peut-être mais là on ne joue pas
que de notre seconde injection
la nuit sur la caméra il est en train de
rieux ouais il est en train de se marrer
bas et enfin de réfléchir à ça il est
parti c'est parti après je vais aller
récupérer un chronomètre après dans un
deuxième temps que c'est un peu comme à
l'époque au tour de france nous à leur
propre potager en regardant les images
pour des contre la montre ou peu il
pointe
il sert mais si on allait calmer
recyclables ouais bah on a essayé de le
faire c'était pas évident est voulu
mettre le chronomètre après mais c'était
pas facile facile à faire mais
finalement c'est peut-être plus sympa je
n'ai pas dites nous dans le tchat ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que vous préférez avec les
caméras des joueurs ou sans moi je
trouve ces bons sympa à fab non non
c'est bien de le faire c'est cool
c'était pas facile alors fab cette
petite position avec le foin à 3 mais
j'imagine sont encore théorique
là c'est sûr que c'est théorique ça ils
ont joué trop vite pour que ça ne soit
pas bon et pour tout une pauvre et
autres sont là avec mes potes de manière
d'une partie longue du n'importe quoi il
faut que la luge ou le temps tableau il
vit pour jouer tempo en fait non raisons
qui jusqu'au bout
pour lui les échecs c'est du ce et du
tempo heureusement que j'ai réussi à
quitter l'audio parce qu'en fait sinon
j'ai peur qu'on les ait eu en audio si
on était très très mal et de leur souris
quoi pique nique
ouais bon c'est un truc comme damage 5
d'ici peu je pense damage cinq fois je
crois dans l'esprit non et on va mater à
l'ancienne bon ok le toit f3 bon je
pense que l'on cherche plus des
compensations baïse au fil d'un pur
bonne marge est géré son clone wars sont
beaucoup mieux et même cavalier e 5 qui
peut arriver cavaliers f3 qui va venir
le fou qui arrive en a je crois je
préfère les noirs en fait la case d3
notre pour un cavale le dire tout dans
cette quête
bon elle en risque déjà kg 400 groupes
h3t lieu trois fois h3g maître par une
fois je crois que rien n'est joué mais
les deux été possible donc du sérieux
des taux de 3,5
mais là on veut pas juste pour en manger
de et faire cavalier g4 bon il va
vouloir qu'un michael jackson 20 kg 4
direct très beaucoup plus tenaces autre
homme
il va peut-être faire tout retour alvin
ouais je trouve nos marques commençant
par fabien toutes ces choses là comment
est-ce qu'on est noirs de 13,6 outre que
nous avons un défi samedi bien mais il
va revenir avec son cavalier e 4 mais en
fait logiquement on est même en
surnombre un numériquement pour le
moment écrit noir faut pas s'affoler un
allèle roy n'ont pas fait les bons et
mauvais repoussé à 5 et 6 où le truc
mais bon sur cinq est tellement sous
attaque quelques jours est un f4
d'entraîneur entre la et canon monde est
plutôt bien non plus peut-être penser h
54 un moment aussi
je pense qu'on doit voir en salle peu
parlants sage 5h qatar ont donné mais
bon on a juste un ton plus quand même
hein et on peut pas tout prendre et la
tour en d3 j'en prends aussi reprendre
la tour on reprend et puis enfin de
l'ordre quand le cas il sera parti on
ramène la tour en d3 mais il reviendra
peut-être ans et 5 avec le cavale mais
ça peut être très grave
[Musique]
façon si on prend et qui prend du
cavalier après tour d'être on aura
peut-être des menaces si vous gelez
cavalli tout reprend g3 avec la tour 1
qui pourrait rester en prise des choses
comme ça mais si par moments ça
marcherait pas puisque adam g 2 peter
brabeck ne pas oublier les personnes ne
pas oublier les score 6-6 jamais après
mais déjà on va les mettre mais de toute
façon les scores vont toujours être à
côté d'une icône md des joueurs en fait
on va toujours avoir le score et entre
les parties je mettrai le chronomètre
je vais aller choper le chronomètre
après ça veut dire quoi alors lâché ziis
je sais pas quel est son truc aussi sur
son twitter aucune idée peut-être que
les blanches du chat peuvent éclairer
mes gongs et heureuse pour défendre h2
du coup la dame l'attaqué de 5
c'est de ne pas prendre l'option
celebuzz des fourrages de ton dessin ok
ça défend f5 et ajustements sache parler
de 5,6 à peut-être possible parce que tu
le désolidarise de six langues à tout
vent tu faire baisser ce machin des
cavaliers et puis après les lettres en
prendre aux curieux rick nash et 10
c'est une espèce de serpent qui fait
qu'il prend 17 mai la fab maison donc si
ça marche ou pas faire jusqu'à deux
tours de 3 t5
il était de 3 peut-être fou ces cinq
alors ouais mais bon du coup votre
téléviseur demi heure je situe le font
ceci croyez pas de mode dirais que c'est
pas leur crainte pour les blancs en fait
ça a l'air de crainte depuis tout à
l'heure pour les blancs cette histoire
mes yeux qu'il faut mieux s'il ya pas eu
de vainqueur qui traînent sur macarthur
a dû tout reprendre eu six femmes
en 101
non mais là on va même menace âge s'en
cachent quatre en fait et on pourra
taper le pion c3 falla parent
probablement s'ils ont poussé 5 c'est un
peu forcé
mais les blancs qu'est ce qu'ils veulent
faire en fait je n'arrive pas vraiment à
comprendre
new survivre j'aurais bien envie de
faire h5 quand même au pire des cas ce
donnera toujours une case pour le roi et
puis on pourra faire h4 après boom au
caire ils survivront h2 il va faire quoi
faire rejoindre à tour g2 et g2 j'ai pas
trop compris à 23,6 mais après j'ai hâte
pas fait ça non plus pas dans le sens où
je trouve tellement dominants pour les
vins caire - qui revient en force mais
je vois pas trop en quoi l'art et pour
ranger 3 d'un projet trois dames j'ai
deux jeunes gardiens et après ya
peut-être des princes et rois one metz
et angers 6 quand même et nous c'est
bien ce que chasse dans la partie mais
où damon chica chica et ses 300 cas
c'est son style aussi à rognonas de tout
le temps à côté de tout en attaque et de
tout temps tout en avant l'initiative
tu crois que pas trop se prendre la tête
à défendre en fait ça n'intéresse pas en
fait bon aller n'était pas en train de
défendre les joueurs pareils qui veut
pas laisser l'adversaire s'activer en
plus les peaux ici les bons quand ils
s'activent bien
ou au minimum nous mais ce qu'on peut
vraiment faire mieux que nul ici
pas sûr je vois pas le clonage est
chiant propose nul à rognan non il s'est
peut-être un peu emballé avec son
sacrifice d'un autre côté peut-on lui
reprocher alors des cadres les systèmes
de londres sa spécialité
ouais bah unique je jouerai jamais et
puis il fait que le jour en fait c'est
génial si vous voulez découvrir ce thème
de vendre je crois qu'elle il est
disponible en fait je sais pas difficile
qui frappe sur f3 relève en fait je ne
sais pas mais bon on tels quels aux
douanes seraient des experts de cette
ouverture
hk boom dans l'esprit complètement si tu
veux jouer comme un mois mais je sais
que ça intéressant san jose 4 h 4 way
par neto déjà joué comme ça j'ai un
élève qui a déjà joué comme ça va jazzer
achetant une claque et la qualité du
temps fou tu t'y vas voir la télévision
que j'ai passées afin de faire ça je
vais faire différemment mais c'est non
mais c'est pas mal souvent parce que
c'est moins il nous faut aussi de son
anr tu fais des 84 donc tu fais un truc
le père et puis là tu montes a même
changé six archers boss que l'on sache
cinq jours chaudement préparation poteau
mais c'est devenu à la mode là depuis
que nous on a commencé à vue comme ça
sur le stream
on est on est en un peu les précurseurs
de cette mode de valence et les pions h4
et h5 direct frontal excuses de qualité
et à dia vais pas prendre évoqué les
prendre de base tandis de faire qu'à
l'écran il veut des retours on comprend
des 30 puis vers foot est roi qui avait
les machins dans trois champs elysées 5
je vois tout le monde doit être
en fait du côté noir si tu prends pas le
pion va juste changer si c'est un jour
tu as tord à chaque joueur joue bien ça
le problème en fait c'est que si tu
prends pas c'est lui qui va te prendre
bon mais existent m de long est ce que
vraiment contrer avec les noirs c'est
possible aussi un bel aline avec fougue
et 5 l'a déjoué tout à l'heure avec en
bulles est d'ailleurs la position là où
qu'ils ont arrêté de jouer à haut niveau
à cause de fouilles b5 c'est hyper
chiant comme vous pouvez 5 c'est
horrible tu as celle que je veux dire
quand tu fais le développement un peu
normal et de côté je prends nous le
montrait donc ce jour non mais là c'est
petit avantage mais ont quand même hein
je pense en tout cas c'est plus agréable
ben prévu sur cette box compte retourner
mais monte à la caisse de saint qui est
à toi avis est parce que la pulpe yon
afp à la colonne h ouverte c'est à la
casse de 5 à vis ta le carré y en a six
qui est mal placée et femmes blancs sont
mieux mais j'ai la sensation que le le
moment difficile dans ce match là ça va
être pourra revenir une source il va
prendre le lead peut-être plus de +3 tu
vois quelque chose comme ça même
peut-être plus 4 avant de bull est
longue il est à mon avis c'est très
dangereux parce que yan yan 5 gamer il
fait des designers là sur la vidéo il
fait des grimaces de malade qu'est ce
que c'est que ces grimaces
il parle je suis pas ci fais pas ces
gens voient l'écart et à juste au dessus
de moi mais c'est ça fait assez peur en
fait franchement ça me ferait flipper la
cgt
qui dit des trucs ce motif d'être jolie
14 contre lui quoi non je sais pas les
vannes oc entend discuter mais les
bonnes il a dit qu'il était avec un de
ses potes en fait les bonnes il joue
avec un copain qui qu'ils avaient cuit
qui 24 quai 24 20 août les façons les
mecs sympas médicaux et il sera juste la
côte et il regarde 24 26 essais et c'est
un nul là pour le servir le thé bonne
presse ça alors après ces quatre c'est
intéressant fabien parce que sa menace
le quartier baie 5.8 par avion mais pas
mal l'action d'arrow diongue mettront
donc sur casse en bessin qui veut faire
plus on prendra me prend et prenant ça
rien de joli gâteau - mais nous les
lignes un peu ces histoires de perdre de
choux et des cases mange adverse faible
peut-être pas trop vu du caïd et deux
pour les récupérer donc ton pions ton du
bon tu veux il a tout fait à la torah
qui tape sur les cavaliers et le pion b
5e pas bougé six cavaliers bouger à lyon
a7 en ligne de mire tu es bien à la fab
note un autre jour entre nous mais bon
déjà partie d'avant il était très bien
les vannes et pierre bardies ce que j'ai
à dire je joue pas de temps mort suisse
la réponse tarde mon argent en bouteille
d'eau et à part ça serait des bouteilles
d'eau moins cher que 4 dollars
abc c'est juste là comme je t'avais
pressé j'ai pris un atout mais bon le
simple fait sa liste comme ça ça me
saoule quoi ces bouteilles à la recette
non je trouve d evian à de dollars ça va
t'as pas vu des eaux locales
je passais confiance
c'est maintenant je descends gourmel
quoi tu vois tu entendras un truc fait
ce que sur cavaliers des deux ne peut
pas essayer de faire cavalier des 5-6
dans ces cas là est-ce qu'on peut pas
essayer d'être malin tête on peut juste
on me donne à 4 tout de suite et on joue
plus pour le maté juste chantage
positionnelle c'est dingue et je pense
qu'on va gagner le pion et on pourra
faire roi des deux apprécient les
changes les filles on voit comme ça en
fait si prend prend prend effet qu'à ud5
juste pour montrer on pourra jouer avec
le roi au centre et protéger le pion et
on récupérera le le pion ces cas dans un
deuxième temps donda magath peut être
pompier n'a pas le goût plus ambitieux
mort a fait irruption et on joue pour
gagner pour une bonne finale avec la
paire de chaussures veut même pas faire
je leur [ __ ] en effet si ceccarelli d2
tu prends le cas wallon f6 tu débarrasse
de ce problème ça va très beaux points
de base
bon et n'a pas cédé de nouveau il le
fait que de tout court ok donc et les
cinq le coût qui nous semblent
intéressants et la paix vous objets 4
donc les joueurs calculé avant dont on
parlait faille calcul est clairement un
fou qui a aidé de cas et des 5 ou est ce
qu'il fallait faire autre chose avant et
là il a dû considérer qu'il avait le
matap ce qui peut menacer fameux 6
échecs sur caillebotis trois points il
peut y avoir damé 6-3 fuite forcée d'un
projet 6 et notre page 6 parce que tu es
fou et on vient d'emprunter cette
manière les gens vous prend de 192
heures juste d'un aussi dans le sens
mais sur damas six tours f7 on peut
peut-être faire pions prend 1,5 comme ça
ça empêche cahiers français trois causes
de france et quatre sur quoi sur vous
pouvez satisfaire ses pions prend 1,5
après on va supposer que doivent aussi à
mais surtout rêve c'est tjrs haye adam
france et 8 il peut même pas protégés de
la tour donc dame g4 c'est très fort en
fait je vais trop vite je veux dire
qualifier ceux qui me sont proches du c4
e nora soit juste des alliances je suis
assez fine ifab peut-être tour ces sites
pour lutter quoi mais ok ça tu attends
si c'était juste pour b1 ailleurs
commencé mes tours c'est ici c'est vrai
que ça paraissait pas idiofa pour lutter
parce que tu empêches dame e.cissé tu
protèges le pion g6 ouais je fais ce que
tu veux mais at-elle juste français
ouais vous pouvez prendre
il faut croire sur la meule six échecs
ans de l'oissu façon ils obligés de
bouger le roi de prusse 1,5 sur échec et
le besogneux mais le quatre français
trois hommes une farouche gamme de
prendre cette voie ce temps on se bat il
doit ya plusieurs moyens de procès et
cavaliers e46 tout bêtement femmes
cavalier e 4 pas si mécontent fin d'une
qualité de loin d'être un pion aux tanks
et des 5 et 6 ont joué à fond dans
l'esprit g4 john wayne et peut-être des
cahiers français 3 et il attaque mais
mon g4 sa faune dans l'esprit
on peut aussi commencer par tour b1
peut-être ai-je eu d'autres bons tours
prend b16 après est comme ça il peut
même plus se prendre avec le car ayant
ses trois passes qui aura dame prono 7,6
l'année de la tourette en 17
d'où vab et après on me dit que les gens
regardent panneaux stream by their faut
arrêter au bout d'un moment on a compris
dans l'esprit à fond en fait mais l'idée
c'est de faire dame 2,7 et 3,7 après la
chose dont tu parlais auquel j bas âge
et 5 dans l'esprit voilà peut-être fou
g2 aussi sa réputation et dames le
système français 8 voilà la france et 8
des gages il vérifie quand même un à
nespouls sait que c'est un joueur un peu
malin triki the world tour ben ouais je
ne me prends ces trois hommes français
qui à première vue brême et il a raison
de vérifier d'être fou prend ces quatre
mêmes d'air on a pensé 4c sur france 4
c'est marrant ce que tu veux pas obligé
de cavaillac aux dames g8 mat avec le
foot organise en plus c'est beau h 4 h 5
g4 g5 c'est trop dans l'esprit 1 je
pense tu ne pouvais pas contre et
d'autres fous de 30 il est marrant que
même même aronian c'est pas si simple
que ça pour lui gagner ça
c'est sûrement très simple mais ne pas
faire le d'emile quoi n'avait pas laissé
de peaux de banane mal aux farc à b4 il
va s'activer
non mais c'est ça le gros point fort de
dépôt en fait c'est un espèce de naka
mur en moins fort non 9h 12h
mais là ça commence à ça commence à
devenir dur qu'il faudra prendre garde
qui doit beaucoup d'essence il résiste
de l'incroyable faillite quand même très
bien pour un mec qui a une tour de moins
parce que jean la tour à tour de jouer
mais pour le moment il lutte
bonsoir à toutes et défendu comment ça
pouvait remettre la marche avant
je ne savais même plus beaucoup de
pièces sur l'échiquier
bush génial non
ces trois schémas mais réussi à mettre à
rosny super mal autant enfin il a plus
que me seconde phase est incroyable il
ya une tour de main contre eux contre
lille 0 4 mondial envie de ça depuis
depuis depuis depuis six sept coups
depuis plus de puits d'une vingtaine de
coups bientôt pascal maes est prodigieux
c'est ce goût puisque ça a enfin
non mais c'était pour eux je sais pas
s'il faisait un prêt move ou quoi mais
il est quand même assez triki un parti
pour le oui/non
15/06 ensemble car wannian de que
karajan ça le fait marrer n'a pas l'air
d'être très très concernés mais bon
c'est peut-être aussi femmes on est un
truc auquel cas on n'a pas pensé mais
peut-être que l'epo une considère qu'il
a de meilleures chances en en bullet et
peut-être qui veut faire moins deux
parties en blitz en fait sur les flics
ou le tank collet l'a quand même fait
couler deux trois bonnes minutes 1 avec
avec saisie ces histoires
bon alors fabu en est on où en est on
dans cette partie j'ai l'impression que
les noirs sont de nouveau bien en tout
cas on égalise et de recevoir ses
anglaise là qui sont fait d'essayer
d'inverser la domination de darian pour
le monde dans les ouvertures fabien
ouais ouais bah sur leur glace dit en
fait surtout venir n'est pas un ensemble
est-ce un millier de mode où tout le
monde jouait donc tu peux plus pendant
longtemps on va déjà jouer en anglais
histoire j'ai un petit truc aura ses
chances et les surprendre un peu de ça
mais là non en fait comme le disait vlad
quand fatiha lisa mort juste qu'elle
soit d'être drôle
wisdom de sa chute le truc a misé
analyse jusqu'au 000 en fait alors
bon ok là les noirs et les blancs
veulent arriver faible et 5 trop tard
pour attaquer les le tempo mais noir
entre partis bien sûr que danser leurs
structures de jour la pression contre 2
qui a une âme donc tu bigote un peu les
blancs à la défense de ce fait on ne
sait jamais des positions que j'ai très
bien je n'ai jamais vraiment compris l
intérêt des blancs doux et ces choses là
bas ce sera hyper maire de châteauroux 5
pierre deux coups je vais faire appeler
les lycéens avec des trucs comme ça et
tu commences à doubler tripler sur sur
ma short et bien chose mais c'est dans
l'esprit et du tour 5 tours 8 était
après la dame qui valait suppan a ligué
allait leur white à tout le monde qui
arrive
bon c'est pas mal un sens on vous prend
de pièces phares de 9,6 il oublie
toujours comme ça pour sa 7ème défend
toujours 17 des quatre îles bien
protégés
norma fortiori sa valeur à tanger c'est
un petit peu recadré jan j'ai bien qu
adrian
bien pas tout à fait bien
nasa un moment qu'on allait demander ses
caméras au final
soit ils bougent sur sa chaîne il ne pas
s'égarer
non
ah il a rebondi de l'autre côté c'est
pas possible insatiable petite fouine
était de trouver quelle série je vous ai
de cette phrase vient et quel personnage
d'annie après pour niveau expert acquis
dans le contexte ça dans le rire et son
bep 5 classique donc pour activer le
sujet de long de la bande et je n'achète
pas les normes je peux faire cb avait
assez solide du coup on parle bien de
cliquer sur l'accolade à qui appartient
plutôt blanc méthane est parente
mais là du coup tu les blancs il est
tranquille de façon il peut pas être moi
peut être mieux c'est autre chose les
licences ça va juste nuque
je suis un peu commentaire parce que
j'essaye de voir si je peux juste bien
faire je vois des petits morceaux de
robien de 4,1 alors qu'elle faisait le
guet celui-ci strates 77 toute trouvée
dans h
voser strauss exactement la phrase était
insatiable petite fouine les experts les
experts bord un point pour pour cette
réponse à ce quiz
je viens de mettre un peu mieux les
joueurs je sais pas ce que ça donne je
suis presque 20 je touche au but ban
doit d'ailleurs c'est tranquille
j'éprouve tout du rejet 10 centimes et
qui optent on n'est ni kehal fable on
est nickel bas des poules entre autres
se parler d'abord même nom mais bon on
le tient plus ou moins là on le tient
c'est quand même beaucoup grimace un
dépôt le dif est de vous faut attacher
nez pourquoi l'armée s'est d'ailleurs
prévu ainsi les qualifiés il jouera
attaché attaché à ça c'est à sa chaise
et pour le prochain match et
qu'obligation d'écouter un à rudolf
pendant tout le peintre le serait donc
l'unission peter barbier ne mentionne
pas de triche avec l'ordi genre
stockfisch en fait ok sur internet a
toujours dit mais pas eux
certes ça c'est des joueurs de l'élite
mondiale peta a gâché la réputation pour
tricher sur un truc comme ça surtout que
là ils ont les caméras et tout quand
même enfin non mais à venir malgré
caméras peuvent atteindre un deuxième
écran enfin s'il veut rentrer chez de le
faire mais après ça va se voir 300 et
voter ben tu dégages peux te prends plus
jamais donc en fait pour ça que des
droits comme ça j'aime bien les ghettos
joueurs ce qui libère une réputation ils
ont un honneur un truc pas là il ne faut
pas tricher prendre deux fins peuvent
pas tout [ __ ] en l'air leur carrière
un truc aussi débile après les tournois
avec même le teil culturel est comme ça
t'es un mec qu'on titre et qui te font
des 8 sur 9 des trucs comme ça lâche eu
beaucoup plus nous avons plus suspecte
est plus active plus basse et plus
soupçonneux et là du coup il cependant
vite vous réservez les trois centrales
élite ou au moins des grands maîtres ou
des gens qui ont vraiment un truc à
perdre enfin si tu triches
c'est vraiment grave et tourne au
courant et lequel papa tu me diras il ya
des mecs qui ont triché et qui
continuent d'être là ils font des
streams mes trucs mais bon ça se savait
en 2000 donc à s'épanouir et avec qui tu
parlais mais en fait oui j'ai compris
mes mais ça se sait rapidement en fait
non une petite tactique laissés en route
par parra revenu mais que se passe-t-il
sur tour des cinq en fait c'est la
question que je me pose et il veut faire
fouge et quatre intermédiaires donc tour
des cinq ça permettrait de faire une
enfilade a récupéré le fou et j'imagine
qu'il veut faire bouger car
intermédiaire ne peut obliger ok donc
votre projet saint-cloud prône aussi une
tour 5 pour orange et 4 500 points c'est
peut-être pas gagnant mais ces pays ne
renie bienvenue et gigoter pas mais
clément sert il a défendu son eau de il
a la possession de la colonne à la solde
de nos vertes vraiment le chic et là
c'est ce qu'est en train de se passer
fab sur l'échiquier donc il va pas
échanger préfère garder les dames mais
ce qu'il faudrait c'est ta meuf cadres
bayo aller n'importe où pour entrer en
ondes et 2021
non pardon pas mon temps pour moi le
foot n'est plus attaqués dans leur
langue et sa part contre coussa devrait
être gagnant pour les plans rugby c'est
quoi ton plus il a toujours posé mais
comme d'hab quand il ya des pièces
lourdes encore ça change pas mal de
choses même aussi peu valorisées et en
plus le juana risque plus faible que
laurent blanc compte qu'avec les
littoraux des huitièmes peut-être dû au
h5n1 jours s'il ya plus de choses on
s'en va peut-être donner un truc un peu
space com tour cinq tours troyes ou tour
3 mai en direct
elles donnent froid j'ai choisi trois
enfants tu défends mais oui c'est dans
la
on doit être l'autre tout autre objet
d'échangé une paire de tours là de toute
façon si on tue à terme atteint donc les
dons pour à vide je pense bouge toi sont
il est mal autant aussi mais là la force
donné pendant cette partie c'est qu'il a
réussi à jouer vite et bien ouais qui
faisait pas grand-chose méditer sans
heurts et d'hommes ces quatre arrivées
du préfet faisaient presbytie ce les
cases blanches se faire un petit truc
sur l'autre aile beaucoup comme dirait
vlady bouge bien mais c'est parler de
deux le ils aiment bouger les pièces
rouge une pièce séparée pour un joueur
d'échecs avait bougé les créationnismes
est complètement pls non je ne veux pas
loin de 6 2 7 5 je n'ai pas envie de
bouger les pièces
baptisé achète en fait tu peux le faire
quand tu veux il couvre les cases pour
n'est pas le rognon éviter d'amérique à
alger cinq idées font ça craint passer
l'épaule un juste peut-être d'am-dam c4
et si tranquille 11
là on me dit que en fait le se
prononcent les a pas mal l'ailé la wah
wah wah
peut-être qu'en fait sa chanson et c'est
ça je voulais jouer contre garé mon père
m'a dit l'ailé là dans ce cas je largue
une plaine envie de ces machin machin à
la fin et je larguerait une tour en 1
[Rires]
ground huit semi rendu à paris mais à
voir h4 en plus à un moment donné ça va
permettre d'attaquer avec le fougueux 8
nous faisons trop excité en fait c'est
un peu comme la cantine il aime bien
bouger que les pièces le fait quand même
de steam pour mac ou en plus il bouge
bien les pièces sous la dent pls en fait
il bouge très bien les pièces vlad
si on regarde si la retenue dont chaque
échec ça peut craindre en cas de seconde
ridicule mais bon vous avez vu dans
l'esprit fab
mais ben je crois ouais si ça il est
dans l'esprit à fond et en battant 2-1 à
porto faut le voir fait 1 mais c'était
bien joué en fait avec quatre jours
amende avec les neuf pays de bloquer
tout ça
bouger une pièce assez rare dacic
bah ils eurent fait la même enfin je
comprends pas il était très mal dans la
première partie n'est pas bon mais du
coup je crois qu'il a un truc puisant
ses shows l'ouverture fait toujours
tassée en train de le conserver leur
tasse qui parler vous sachiez joué une
mauvaise variante à hayon change du tout
mais il est tout le temps en train de
bouger la tête et de parler en fait les
producteurs je ne sais pas ce qu'il fait
en fait je ne comprends pas feed the
children
mais il fait que des mouvements bizarres
c'est très étrange comme sont répartis
nom est en fait tu as passé par la
caméra puisque les vols de bon t'as
l'air d'un comme dirait vlad un petit
pépère en train de jouer à la source
comme si vous souhaitez a commenté le
brûlement en arrière c'est très étrange
eux
tu as eu le 032 chasser dynepo il est
juste dans le turf eu mais c'est ça en
fait je pense et ça s'est il est en
discussion avec super beats en fait elle
supervise qui passe à gauche à droite ne
le voit pas à l'écran mais je le redis
c'est la voix ça respecte blanche à ta
ta ta quelqu'un avec une unité avec une
petite balle en fait dérailler la fin
d'essayer de vous premier set nous écrit
il aime bouger les pièces et son corps
aussi nebo qu'est ce que déclare c'est
jouable
non je suis bien son os ya peut-être
poussé quatre échecs et moi je suis mal
aussi mais c'est un vote d'investiture
tarde pas faire un truc comme des cartes
à puce dans mon fils à jo non juste un
mont des cats qui aurait peut-être aussi
aux 6 après michael brand g4 et depuis
ça va tomber mais juste un joli mat sur
watch 8
je montre non très un match très très
étrange
non c'est lui c'est très étrange qui
soit retourné sur les lieux du crime les
peau retournée sur les lieux d'un crime
a été de faire cavalier e cat et gigoter
encore voilà il gigote de partout femmes
n'ont-elles vous y menacent les
problèmes de qom et lima sky problème ne
peut peut-être un moment donné à une ton
point f4 bon tant d'autres mais bon
draghi n'est pas encore sorti du cadre
non mais t'as quel point f25 aussi qui
peut être ce nom mais en fait il ya des
compensations aux déviations active le
taux refi sur une colonne tour d en face
de la dame rouge et cette boue qui est
toujours libre est quelqu'un de bien
placer défend tout joueur très bien joué
qu'elle est un peu 2,5 peut-être cinq
flash 2 je suis pas hyper ravi le sympa
je suis content je suis pas content je
prends le centre mais je ferme mon fou a
donc l'idée d'un trou d'air france du
semi actif quand même à faire pour les
niveaux prochain on va faire ses 3 et
puis après ça va aller pour les blancs
si tu laisses faire se laisse faire ces
trois ça va 5 jouer couach de jouer tour
il veut gigoter sur la colonne f
peut pas faire quelque chose comme
karine icher 3 parce que j'allais dire
rêve pour échanger les cavaliers est un
peu soulagé le pion f2 n'attends rien
qui dit que n'ait pas fait aussi des
grimaces chelou c'est vrai qu'il fait
des grimaces un peu mais on a très très
bien fait de mettre les caméras je suis
très heureux des caméras je pense qu'il
ya na cas quand il ya des pauthe a
besoin des caméras en fait qu'est ces
cinq peut-être vous activer la vacquerie
blanc peut-être quelque chose comme dan
des deux tours d un c'est pas d'âme des
deux peut-être dame eu deux compères
mettent à nu en d2 lyon 2-2 je sais que
tu vas bouger le quartier g3 il va
devoir impérieux qu'alinghi c'est pas
simple de réaliser en fait on dirait
sans qu'une journée mais après ça il
faut un truc c'est juste pas sain pour
personnes âgées des noirs si on relâche
un peu que c'est elle en ressortira yvon
volare marquion non ce qui est sûr c'est
que moi je perdrais qe2 couleurs basso
de bonbons qui fera face à evian-tg au
conflit mais je rencontre les deux
joueurs tu mets à la place tu mets
contre nespouls avec les blancs je me
fais défoncer tu me mets avec les noirs
contre aronian dans quatre coups il ya
plus de compensation 3 voit remettre le
caviar c'est pas simple cavalia 4 c'est
pas mal joué il joue à gauche il joue à
droite si j'ai un peu de partout il
gigote trop et comme sur sa chaîne en
fait je suis cool dorion je mets un
petit coup à gauche j'ai eu un petit
coup à droite et un peu insupportable
mais là et même au centre de l'écran il
siège de votre centre de l'écran
maintenant
b 3 quand même donc là je fais tu de ces
trois là et en plus il peut à venir
cette vers des cinq après deux mois
voilà un moment pour suppléer mieux
avoir naissante mais chez de droit n'ont
pas le droit pour prendre 3 non tu veux
tu joues un autre coup coups interdits
bah on ferme attenante encontre ou non
mais il voulait pas le faire ce qui est
le pion c2 qui tombait oui enfin là
peut-être maintenant tu donnes une idée
aussi ses 4 sid à ces quatre c'est fort
ça va bien vu parce que prise en passant
pas possible donc l'e3 n'a plus de
soutien et du coup ça se crée un pion se
passait la barre par poussée qu'elle
trois jolies mais il faut cotiser cette
beauté l'esthétique visuelle
sinon c4 arrive ces attaques est de
qualité ça partout d'enseignement pour
ça que fergie dans les bonnes conditions
ce sera très bien pour lui mais bon la
c4 c'est une menace encore plus fort que
tu reprends le 3 way parce que ton
retrouve toute façon tu peux le faire un
jour h55 c'est un peu le coup de
quelqu'un qui sait plus quoi faire
bon c'est pas mauvais parce qu'il ya h 4
h 20 km et versez un peu le coup de
quelqu'un qui est un peu en manque de tu
vois d'inspiration d'inspiration après
c'est peut-être un bon coup quand même
mais ça sente a plus trop trop l'idée on
peut faire un truc comme food et six
pouces et 5 d'ailleurs avec les blancs
tam t3 pourquoi ben pourquoi pas
pourquoi pour hommes
ok c'est pas con comme dans le jura sont
déclarés sans exploser g2 et g2 est roi
du coup mais sachant pas trop dam des
trois parce qu'en fait sa part pas du
tout la menace âge qu'attache 3 eilat a
de nouveau envie de faire un tour
prendre trois mais tu vas juste perdre
un tempo qui arrive à l'échoppé le pion
g62 quelque 3,6 d'accord le procès de la
casse ces quatre pour chasser le cavale
à 162 finale ça va moins bien
attente au moins mes coups ça détourne
ses doublés qu'est minimum tu prends ce
qui validerait un grand modèle d
apprendre qu en fait y apprendre du pub
pour soutenir toutes leurs prêts et ils
augmentent du pion il veut mettre la
tour en quatre affaires tour 4 la femme
ilva des flandres sanction mais c'est
peut être la moins âgée je pense ouais
match des rois prend et après peut-être
fou et je leur tour f 5 ou un ordre
secret mais du coup prises angers cette
prise en d4
quatre ans monique que dans dota et
quelqu'un qui a rien héros qui s'appelle
mais pau et faut savoir que que des
poètes un excellent joueur de dota
je crois qu'il a le niveau
semi-professionnel à d'état il avait
même réfléchi c'est après ce dont je me
rappelle c'est pas normal qu'on soit
ouais il préférait y aurait préféré
d'autres échecs en fait enfin ils
préfèrent d'auto échec je pense encore
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus intéressant
dota 2 en fait c'est très bien pour les
bourses affable très bien joué de la
part d'un runyan mais il est en forme
aronian un pas trop parler là parce
qu'on a le temps on va encore passer des
heures ensemble mais mais bon c'est un
dessin des tout meilleurs joueurs du
blitz en ce moment du monde c'est
l'homme en forme
les 154 pour le bon allez c'est pas
beaucoup 154 personnes pour regarder ce
match c'est très très peu c'est très
très peu de sources sisters de john
wayne de twitch aussi du fait que ce
soit plus plus difficile d'avoir d'avoir
des gens qui ce qui se trouve pas sur
l'estrie n'y a pas de joueurs français
y'a pas garé allez on pourrait on
pourrait faire 250 ce soir ce serait
déjà pas mal
allez on se bat en ce bas je vais
remettre un lien vers les liens après à
la fin de la partie pendant ses deux
pions pu semer ses deux pions doublé
mais c'est pas vraiment les pions ici je
pense qu'ils sont importants fabien
c'est plus l'activité blanche aux siens
un troisième cas un vrai puis valeureux
noël vous exposez quoi après non mais
c'est jamais simple et en plus il peut y
avoir des perpète et puis alors
évidemment si tu as deux heures à la
conduite doit être gagnant assez
facilement mais avec quelques secondes
la bonne décision je suis pas sûr mais
après dun verger quatre ans là-bas un
damier cassetête dame b 1
mais dans ma chance chez les dames et
messieurs dangereux dans les vergers 2
novembre 2004 logique pourquoi
du coup mais bon ça reste dangereux il
veut peut-être faire d'alger 3 au
prochain il va menacer tout re 5 et
après c'est quoi c'est toujours
compliqué gamache un tour et d'un pro f
2 et d'un preuve de haye adam et
d'agréer six échecs échec et une photo
mais même parce que le truc c'est quand
tu vas partir en c3 il y aura demain un
échec tant que père pète d'un fn 3 6 3
rodica à willer damas et trois à très
bien jouer ça c'est joli technique de
renault avec quelques secondes sur la
pendule déjà avec des heures choix
peut-être même pas grave de faire
tétreault mais c'est peut-être pas
gagnant quand même du goût de ses 54
ouais mais bon j'imagine pour des cas
d'échec des enfilades par des échecs
reprendre du temps répondu le 2 mai
faire damas trois échecs
je redescends ouais mais c'est
je pense qu'il a pas vu parce que sinon
j'aurais répondu tempo je pensais il
n'avait pas vu dans huit dans cette
deuxième place est une belle partie à
fab
oui je sais pas il a craqué les goûts de
bons fous sera quoi les remarqués sur la
caméra sa femme va d'une bande étroite
de 3 ce soir et c'est pas fini c'est pas
fini et à contremaître il est inscrit
dans tous les sens
en tant que spécialiste international je
suis très heureux aya patour h4 à il
réussit à les changer les pâturages
cascades avait un contrôle et d'annoncer
une fougue le sol et s'est pas fait
attendre et c'est pas fini encore à tous
ces plantes en quoi normalement c'est
facile mais bon
cette partie à rebondissements j'ai
récupéré 1,1 en mai bon et juste qui a
rapproché paris
enfin attention tu vas le poisson c'est
bon de marans est parti j'ai pas vu la
caméra pendant quand il a fait la gaffe
et ça c'est assez comique
c'était une partie très sympa c'était
une partie très agréable fabien ça va ça
vient mais vrai ok je devrais je n'ai
vous qui coupent ouais ça fait partie du
folklore de la partie de nous de nouveau
cette anglaise ya-il chris cris il crise
qui lui dit bonjour bonsoir à tous à une
crise ou bonjour encore un il fait
encore jour je traiterai jour là les 3t
tête en plein jour
moi j'suis un crépuscule papam encore
crépuscule sur fin de journée c'est la
même position qu'on est lors de la
partie précédente n'en à quelque chose
près le cas et c'est encore cette
histoire dans des sacs noirs et précis
mais c'est que je n'aurai ils sont tous
bien joué ce truc moi non quand je la
trouve quelque chose qu'on le joue en
fait marin
jacques a dit ladd a dit nouveautés non
mais les traits respectives la juste le
respecte tout le monde n'a pas tout oui
le top mondial aussi oui après qu'un
accent aussi fédération kazakh ils ont
carrément invité vous faire un stage
d'entraînement n'ont pas cessé très
qualitatif car entraînement basé sur
pour leur équipe nationale
louison sûr comme pour nos modes alors
cavaliers d2 tu connais mes instincts
j'ai envie de faire f 5
mais mon pote je te nomme non moi je
fais chier juste à roye jeu suit en fait
je suis un barbare en fait j'aimerais
bien que l'udc et des 4 b 6
le crois je comprends ces cinq si j'ai
besoin je crois aussi que ok si je fait
qu'il y ait des 4 il a jugé 4 et vous
prouver sa tâche
d'où l'idée de faire f 5 bonnes chansons
que je dois juste faire peut-être du tmb
3 dans le premier set mais en fait je
rêve c'est la mission sur f5 juste pour
montrer un sur f5 dam des trois je vais
faire rage suite en fait bondir
d'armement mais cet été 4 e bonds
d'autres 3 au coa même aux non mais dans
l'esprit il a commencé par dame 17
donc il me menace ni veut faire b6 je
pense c'est le jour j
bon ben de tours à cette race est c'est
le cycle on protège le pion baisse est
donc inaudible paul pascon de beci sont
les autoroutes sans faute ce qui se
passe by cissokho b 6 mois une qui a
donc changé 4 - guillaume bon et là
maintenant braqués d'être tombé un web
et du gondor je ne sais si ce nom matin
on peut pas le donner ce pion je sache
c'est vrai je vais rachat qu'on s'en
fout c'est exactement ce que le ferrage
c'est beaucoup plus dans l'esprit bas
possible et sur gt5 je sais pas que
cette dame est peut-être le dire trois
ouvertures par an ces six temps fou au
bout ça c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
blanc tu vas faire qu'a eu 6 cas et
c'est ça qui a eu six ans peu à quel
point je serai obligé de revenir au jeu
rocks mais sinon ce qu'on va devenir ans
et 5 pour aller taper des trois mais
qu'elle saisit c'est très bien on menace
le pur à 5 au passage je comprends pas
pourquoi il réfléchit
ce soir jusqu'à la situation actuelle
prend des trois directs en fait les
hommes de choses je suis très heureux de
ce coup
donc les rolmen man 2 milliard et demi
on voit le score à côté des pseudos
d'autres choses tatoué ou iv gt soit sur
le montage
définitivement je pense qu'en fait une
épaule ne s'assied sur rien de manière
définitive en fait je dire si je veux te
faire [ __ ] quatre dames 31 qui prend
1,5 en échange tout genre prend juste b
7 kg d'échangés g4g avoir du mal à
perdre
la fin du minimum que je vois pour les
noirs sur ce que j'ai sûrement faire
juste vous prend vous prendra me cissé
puis je reste quand même un peu tout
sharp sont un peu chapeauter le jeu
dassault systèmes dessin g4s comprendre
et rodez 3g 6h j'ai quand même d'objets
cannot swim où sont vos deux longeurs
sougé système le coup le plus logique de
base ce que tu double les pions noirs en
fait j'ai du mal à comprendre pourquoi
ils s'essoufflent et puis en ce cas on
peut même juste faire à alger et je vois
pas la plus value de jouer avec les
pions doublé angers au lieu d'avoir que
l'adversaire les pions double en fait
jusque là il s'est volontairement je
vois pas la plus value du truc il décide
un peu de se jouer dans ce genre apporte
le juke
là si tu veux vraiment justifier ton
truc il faut faire dame prend des trois
je pense ou de décès ou d'un mètre 5
suède à me ranger 4 justifie rien du
tout non ok bon détroit s'est distingué
tour 17 maintenant achevé cinq à sept
tours des subprimes est tombé 5 bien
jouer tu protèges à 5 tu as ta que 5 tu
prépares tour 17
en fait j'aime bien les peaux maintenant
bon il n'y a pas forcément grand chose
mais tout d'un coup mais surtout qui
sait ni mal autant en plus pour faire ça
il est bon ou les bonnes comme vous
le wolof tour à 6 qu'est ce que c'est
que ça bah tant mieux outillés pour un
sens que j'imagine mal une aussi ses
bons temps des huit ans passent trop
près mais y aura peut-être d'un match 4
échecs en fin de la route avec dame
point cette invention ou bon sens voilà
le rêve s'est fait exploser sur des dom
c'est captivant et 20 jours intenses où
échangent des vanités pour le moment
c'est une époque qui signe un peu tout
seul dans le nord la neige devait
presser à hauteur d'homme projet 4 on
s'adapte au mode s'utilise disons-le qui
prend cinq ans et ça ça devrait aller
bien nul va sûrement de nous des
personnes comprend cinq danseurs et
toura intermédiaire il ya quatre ans
mais cette fois les tours b 8 tours un
match à lui tout rien je pense qu'elle
est ici six mais ok admettons mais une
épaule en fait il veut jouer sur le roi
fait des noirs malgré la finale hommes
sur la pendule de wind et des coups de
feu sur le premier but qui vaut il un
tournant final ils sont cools ils le
jouent ces chevaleresque chevaleresque
mais bon les vannes oc cheval reste
quand il joue la tacc aussi a bien joué
mais surtout francis latour france et 8
est sûr et surtout reprend binauld
je donne de l'heure comme ça il n'y a
plus cette course aux huitièmes donc
plus de
deux réseaux de maths et puis la pluie
comme il n'a non plus comme tant
d'autres il un jour ça va parler je
pense pas qu'ils soient que ce soit en
fait même d'un point de vue pratique non
si c'est pas les blancs qui sont encore
mieux même peut-être même d'un point de
vue au jld et objective en fait taire
pas que pratique parce que le roi
arrivant j'ai 51 coupe arabe comme tout
réussi ce qui pourrait donner envie
marche pas que ce qu'a laissé cinq
échecs ça m'a compliqué jeudi c'est tout
haut c'est hyper dur de bouger la
hyperion c'est de bouger
s'approche avec ses pièces petit à petit
c'est horrible il va voir qui le
chassent la fable il faut le chasser a
marqué pas mal
y a plus de rejet sont tus 10.5 et du
défenseur des jambes et mes mains il va
falloir réussir à ne plus bouger
ce qui est super important
non il avec lecavalier en d6 il a bien
il est bien placé ce cavalier j'y tiens
beaucoup de cases importante de maison
peut-être faire même 4 à un moment donné
maintenant j'aurais bien envie de faire
le carton me débarrasser d'un peu tout
genre là le cadre boom foray cédric et
puisque six f4 camille ça peut devenir
dangereux après pour les blancs mais le
centre bell je pense qu'ils doivent
sinon il est juste un peu moins bien
enfin on remarque peut tout prendre 4
prendre c'est cet essai nul juste ok
propose nul avec les blancs dans bien de
plus par là royal parce que c'était
vraiment pas évident avec si peu ça
recommence
vous reprendrez théâtre je pense qu'il
est grand fan de lydéric h4 et h5 de
nouveaux changera compris ça déjà
il retenir pas d'anti l'obligation de
jouer avec la caméra à lui mais oui ils
ont l'obligation alors c'est pas du tout
pour la triche ou quoi que ce soit c'est
juste que ça fait partie du spectacle
ça fait partie du tournoi c'est vrai
c'est tout simplement c'est tout
simplement une demande de chess points
comme organisateur du tournoi
pour rendre le stream plus vivant et je
pense que c'est une bonne chose fab
autre chose parce que moins on peut plus
nous dire ouais mais juste sur internet
on voit pas les joueurs si nous entendre
a toujours des idées dans le rouge ou
quoi on voit les joueurs
ainsi sur internet 2 de l'avant plus le
point positif sur internet c'est qu'on
n'a pas de problème de retransmission
parce qu'en bleed sinon on n'arrive pas
vraiment à suivre la fin des parties
d'habitude on a des mauvais ton dos des
îles vague de fous qui arrive et on peut
vraiment pas comprendre ce qui se passe
alors que là ça permet de ça permet de
bien voir les parties et de bien voir
les moments intéressants qui sont les
fins de partie puisque par exemple dans
la partie qu'on a vu avec la finale ou
dépôt a pas pris le perpet ma finale de
dames on a vraiment bien pu suivre ce
qui se passait c'est quand même
intéressant alors qualifié 4 il veut y
veut il veut recommencer avec ces
menaces méchante sur sur eve de yatta de
karaj et prend des cinq la femme mais
c'est très compliqué l'idée section d'un
grand dessein qui a poussé quatre oui
mais bon c'est le bordel ce qui a
peut-être kf2 et suroît problème je sais
pas si on va des éléments comme d'hab
tata avantages à long terme antoine de
tarlé tout faut juste furieux c'est pas
la face va partir dans l'activité à fond
puisque toi ta part aux quais etc et non
oui
ok donc là surplus on prenait 4 y avait
un joli truc que je vais montrer ses
cavaliers cet échec 3 a chuté qualifier
6 matches 6 tranches
[Musique]
ça marche aussi
thom evans titre en jeu ce n'est pas sur
le temps de le montrer mais sur watch 8
à main sa part le montrer mais si vous
pouvez revenir la partie pré-saison sur
un citoyen avait tout reprocher ttda
machin et d'un point si ce matin ça fait
plus deux pour les vols à une écossaise
on sait que liane il joue il joue assez
souvent l'écossaise pas assez souvent
par rapport aux autres joueurs du haut
niveau est atteint de ce qu'il joue le
plus souvent
tiens joueurs nouveaux trucs que je fais
un truc que je paye saïda fâche 4 n'a
pas fait ces quatre noms tous essayent
un peu c'est ainsi que dans mon iphone
je crois que les noirs sont ok tiens je
tiens c'est pas mal ce qui est en train
de faire ça me donne envie d'essayer
c'est tellement dans l'esprit de faire
rage quatre tours âge 3
c'est peut-être le truc le plus dans les
deux plus dans l'esprit en fait on y
dépeint à part sur facebook sur twitter
est requise il de chess comme française
des choses comme ça pour que plus de
gens viennent quoi je pense le match et
pas mal l'idée belle partie donc voilà
ça retrouve nous gênait pas quoi well et
on partage de partout c'est vrai que ça
partage pas beaucoup c'est un petit peu
craignos témoin au final on se retrouve
on ne sera plus de ce crime sur les
haies chacun sa façon c'est comme ça que
ça finira à force ne pas partager
c'est le risque qui est encouru c'est le
risque qui est en cours ifab par la
communauté ils ont déjà risqué tarder la
série vidéo sur kasparov qu'ils ont
sauvé la sauveront ils la ressentent une
partie man show soit pour montrer la
partie de la résurrection de la
particule a proposé 1
quand il avait 14 ans ouais ouais on
avance jeudi le match garde 84 sur le
premier mais de façon je pense qu'on ne
fera qu'une vidéo
j'imagine que les 500 like we soir est
congelé lille n'étaient pas des bords de
l'arve en conférant la série est sauvé
pour l'instant mais j'ai peur que c'est
pas qu'elle le soit sauvée que que pour
une vidéo en fait ce soir bien sûr ça de
pris le changera convaincre combattre un
nombre de like et un temps imparti aussi
par exemple un mois ce que je sais en
fait elle va être sauvé tous les tous
les six mois et c'est plus vraiment une
série en fait donc et nous tant pis ils
ont un tien rappel je sais ma piqûre de
rappel
pascal go qui les lie ces nouvelles
idées dans les ouvertures du genre h4
qu'on sent la présence de les ordis dans
l'est dans la préparation avec désormais
pas sur notre leurs dix au trot la
mascotte juger une qualité très vite si
justement facile à jouer pour les noirs
s'il ya pas de mal direct mais tu bouges
mal des pièces et les blancs ribes se
positionne en fait ouais mais c'est la
présence de l'ordi dans le sens où le
radi a tellement égaliser de partout et
on est obligé de chercher des variantes
comme ça je pense
bon mais en fait à revenir nuit ce qui
veux simplement faire c'est s'est
prolongé cinq au prochain puis faire
aucun petit roquet petit ou même chose à
tours dans la tour il vient de
l'apprendre il veut juste faire sur fion
froid je crois j'imagine dame projet
cinq échecs
je sais pas ce qu'il fait des posters
visage du cratère
parce que le roi est un coup dur ok
c'est pas nous c'est les tontes arcade
b5 et b6 ou quoi l'on retrouve les mêmes
qualités pour ça mais là c'est chez je
pense ça marche pas du tout mais bon
rien de très dangereux en pratique c'est
en veut peut-être juste rauque et je
pense peut-être ses hits aussi
quelquefois je crois vous fait vos
projets d'autres peut-être je sais pas
sympathique et chaleureuse que puis on
met peut nous saouler
mais bon même mais cette impasse adam g
d'autres autres baies vitrées dessus
cahill et 5 comparé aux démons première
option
je dois voir ce qu'on peut
je vends pas de deuxième et options pour
le moment bat en brèche 2 sociale belge
face c'est vraiment une temporalité de
tet kalé 5 nous donc c'est à dire que
tourcoing f2 l'idée c'est que ça
menaçait matin ses deux mais qui est des
cinq mosquées cette fourchette éléphants
et défend un associe bessette benita
près puisqu'elle a plus la tension la
huitième et a mûri qui ne veut mettre un
petit tweet j'ai été mentionné et bien
bien jouer amorim un point aussi de lier
le tout
pour ces huit bien joué là parce que sur
dame prend des six est peut-être tour
des huit savait que clouage très
désagréable sur à la colonne des oui non
ce recompte décision non mais le
problème c'est que si tu vas prendre à 7
il y aura peut-être fou pranger de après
ça quand même commencé à faire beaucoup
outre deux tours fra 82 encore mieux
bien vieux fab mais peut-être sur tour
des huitièmes où ces quatre échecs
ouais c'est ça arrive et ça oui si un
scooter 0h fille de 17 ans des 8 a
essayé jouer ses cartes et guides encore
sauf miracle mais je m'ennuie incarne
l'épousé 4h 8b
à temps et si on combine attend on va
essayer de combiner ont fait pousser 4
donc il fait froid je suis ton fait
bessette il fait tourbe et 8 ont fait
cavaliers 4 ouais mais obligé en bien
des coeurs en traitant comptait 600
prend des deux autres que je pense
qu'assez ouais mais pas sûr pas sûr
c'est ce qu'on va voir arriver
c'est sûr qu'il va jouer sa toute façon
il a il n'a pas le choix dans le cas du
cadre d'une promenade bref on va faire
dame prend des deux ouvreurs prend de
nouveau demandé c'est l'heure des sens
et la vente vous faire en train de
parler en mon coeur va vous allez avoir
à courir le tour de france et en plus on
va faire tout reprend ses quartiers dans
38 états et surtout prend des âges
peuvent peut-être faire tout reprend des
six est surpris en france et 8 france et
8 personnes qui protège la tour on
l'avait pas vu symbol ouais on est
complètement mérité les fetwas oui non
mais là à faire là c'est gentil mais
wang et de toutes pièces pour les hommes
mais ce poste mais on peut pas essayer
de puteaux larié la dame contre la tour
jordan prend des deux bessette et puis
il a joué avec la cage de plus juste
dommage que josy haven le boulet vos
notes mal avantage c'est que tu
t'assures de ne pas perdre quelque part
parce que dans l'autre est plus dur à
défoncer les machins des menaces de mal
je pense qu ils font en bessette et à
tours angers 6e fois en dix-sept le
machin
il envoie les cuire à four en plus les
pions sont sur noir le fruit de quatre
blanche sais pas si c'est intéressant de
faire x 6 pour échanger les fouilles de
rester contre le cavalier normalement ça
gagnant quand même normalement et
changer les pièces est une bonne chose
oui bon je n'avais pour convertir un
avantage
voilà la tête du g4 le jeter un coup
d'oeil sur les caméras
mais voilà à l'air très très très
tranquille mais ce qu'on voit dans les
partis il est tranquille dans son jeu je
ne sais pas ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il a
vraiment fait mais il dit qu'il est
beaucoup plus tranquille dans sa vie en
général je voue beaucoup moins un échec
car en fait d'accord il parle avec lui
déjà il m'avait dit ça quand c'est son
premier déclic c'est quand il avait pu
vivre à berlin il qu'il est plus trop se
soucier des problèmes d'argent et je
veux voir mon échec pour jouer aux
échecs bat pour survivre et n'est déjà
qu'elle était plus à des to et on le
voit a tendance à des mecs prendre moins
malade et voyez jamais personnellement
de perdrix et ils partent pas en
claquant les portes ou quatuor
mais la bonne pour loi caméra il
traitement un peu tranquille une bande
face
il est très très sain il est dans il est
dans ses chaussons
il va convertir cet avantage très
tranquillement il va activer le roi des
rois f6 s'il peut faire wife 6,3 g 5
points f4 et puis après 10 étapes tirs
ratés madrid yann d'abandonner une
partie normale mais là effectivement il
doit jouer le chat retombe et la pendule
au revoir il ay les routes bientôt c'est
bon on a clairement y croire et à poney
ou si ils l'attendent 8 45 ans dix ans
de cette chance c'est joey des 15 plus
gros il faut limiter l'hémorragie quand
même se pressaient de plus trois passes
et deux parties non non c'est quand tu
voulais tu peux te prendrais tu peux
faire plus 5 +61 donc c'est un ordre de
la confiance d'avant c'est plusieurs
mais direct à partir de +4 pour les
bulles est depuis ce 4 + 5 ça devient un
jeu allumé la lumière ça devient grave
en fait voilà ce n'est pas encore super
grave ça pourrait le devenir
théorisée donc le plus 3
l'un d'eux qu'ils pensent qu'ils jouent
pour limiter l année qu il a appris la
répète alors il faut vous pouvez et et
quoi d'autre hélas aucun parti n'a pas
commencé le parti encore là fait
l'impression tout cas pas chez moi non
donc c'est le moment partage allez on
partage ou partage sur facebook par le
jus partout on en parle à ses amis le
match est bien lancée on a compté jeté
un chat comme une partie d'échecs
normale en cinq minutes
c'est quand même le nouveau centre
mexes enfin de se marrer dans le chat et
10 qui a dit que rené pommier h était
favori du match c'est moi j'attends donc
la chance n'était pas le seul à penser
que n'ait pas été favori mais moi aussi
en fait je pensais que ça allait par va
avoir un il ya encore beaucoup de bien
au début mais en fait tout les rognons
très impressionnant très tranquille tu
es donc on va dire qu'ils sont jeunes
sortent de pierrick je vois une verte
rare de la pierre servier que font un
cadeau tu as ste foy et a joué les
volets pajak des cinq corps de chaque
parti tel laisser jouer il a compris il
fallait changer ses ouvertures depuis un
moment un pour les peaux il est il est
allé trop dense est dans cette position
où il était un peu dominé et là aussi en
fait il m'a pas l'air d'être très bien à
royal il va remettre le fou ou 3 il va
jouer avec 4 il va chasser le cavalier
il ya la case b6 vert jusqu'à et prend
des cinq là je pense même plus on prend
d'ailleurs pourquoi pas un jour ne joue
pas contre 24 des cas
peut-être qu'à y ces captures f4
rassemblement non mais là il va prendre
quelques valises pleines
t'as le plus logique 1 et 3 4 s'agit
pensée pour lui dicter ses 4 mai but 3-2
qui sait si sûr b3 tous les gars j'aime
bien
et qui a eu lieu trois ans assure
beaucoup de suisses il ya maintenant la
structure carrée u13 équidés f4 après ça
a l'air pas mal
les c4 aussi du jour ne m'en ont dit
qu'is chicane je ferai c'est on commence
par c4 et c4 m'a l'air plus plus
important jusqu'à f4 on ne pourra
toujours le faire plus tard y'a pas
avoir segat sur 90 je veux faire
caillasser 6 d'échangés fructueux noir
abattu fixe avec le sourire au centre et
tu joues pour que des 4l jouer pour une
4 voies ferrées avec du tour b3 et
public du tour auto h3 de vingt jours ne
serait pas mal faire
qui aida main b4 très jeune je sois
raisons du monde d'être à fond dans
l'esprit 1 est-ce que c'est trop dans
l'esprit pour aronian ou pas telle est
la question
bon c'est 4 ok je pense que ton idée qui
haïssez 6e 5 à 10 des cas tu étais à ces
perspectives qui venons poteau de blé 4
ou trop de la tour des trois en fait le
buzz et se sentent aussi pas le temps de
faire comprendre tomber c'est ce que tu
me découvre la davrays
têtes d'ânes b33 je pas les enlever la
protection du four et la tête je vous ai
droit il ya une gardent tout leur
contrôle et semi joueurs entre eux vis
n'est pas de tout repos
l'algérie qualité sont compliquées
enfin il ya 30 mégawatts dans la tronche
est ce que tu es contente par un temps
aux pommes et à peut-être se prendre des
quatre mêmes direct maintenant on fait
toujours un peu vite way dans la neige
dans une demande de des questions à
poser
il bouge bien les pièces qu mais j'adore
cette expression de l'année vous je
viens les vétérans 17 à la série
pourront maintenant plus à tourves
arrive en c1 tours fc 1 est en fait un
run il va juste à replacer ces pièces
parfaitement bon il a pris les chemins
peu un peu étrange de tortueux
m'appartient mais au final la f1 c'est
déjà quelque chose c'est déjà un bon
accomplissement des 9 5 3 5 t il ces
deux échanges qui fit que je tente vous
pouvez 4 - ça donne ce qu'on peut faire
médecin qui ces deux metteurs en scène
un portable note à 18h05 qui avait des
fuites déjà comme ça après au début
attendre tour c'est bien de faire aussi
on peut pas largué je retour prend des
quatre qualités 5 6 6 mais bon goûter
sera jamais clair et 10,6 en place mais
aussi suite à des trucs non ça je suis
même pas et tu peux te battre pour un
avantage mais peut-être d'un point de
vue pratique c'est plus simple à jouer
quand on se trouve à l'autre en ville
bush a bien raison ce truc et il verrait
de 5,94 étonnant ça assez c'est assez
difficile à évaluer non c'est vraiment
pas clair où il ya un des deux joueurs
qui est mieux d'après toi mon pote là je
dis trouve peut-être
j'ai peur mais n'ont jamais clair
puisque benda tout d'une belle case fin
des syndicats pour son beau symétrique
elles sont toutes les deux sympa on a un
mauvais coup mais bon si je tend à
s'ouvrir en noir ça donne mais là je
pense je refuserais les changements pour
y échanger cavalli près de me trouvais
juste avec moi mais tout le monde sait
aunis me soit tata et b6 alors ouais
michael sata qui se passe quoi
silverlight 5 9 s'est échangé à un
cavalier c'est pas mal non plus
d'options et 5 va prendre la case aussi
ils sont souvent des perspectives
il préfère ça prendrait en vend des
cookies petites imprécisions de dépôt a
marqué 10 buts a rugi il reste un match
si cela en plus peut-être damage six
femmes lastours h3b est dangereux ça bon
ça n'avait pas marché mais je veux dire
il a joué hyper vite il n'a pas pu
vraiment le calcul et n'est pas jojo
german d'ailleurs y'a un truc étonnant
c'est pas toujours les joueurs qui ont
gelé plus vite tu as été les meilleurs
en bullet après c'est elle était très
bizarre ça ne trouble pas raison ouais
c'est pas dur les mecs qui voulait plus
vite qu'ils sont qui sont les meilleurs
avec peu de temps
mais bon on est pause ça va encore ce
qui peut m il peut encore mettre cavale
et en russie si gigote pas mal encore
c'est pas si grave en réalité ce que les
frites mccain tous ceux qui on parle le
moins qui ronge le plus ouais j'avais
d'autres oui mais là il va pas juste
wilfert juste d'amener ça être je pense
oui je pense
jusqu'à ce jour j je met évidence vous
pouvez vous encore de toujours des
soucis je sais pas quel point les blancs
font mieux en fait enfin peut-être que
bizarre ce serait super vite ça te pose
après les bonnes puisque les fait assez
précis mais sûrement qu'il devait un peu
mieux et la fin de l'effet de serre au
boucher bon après c'est peut-être chez 5
contre attaque mais a dépassé focus
nepomniachi au dessus de moi bon de
macheist nombre de traitements répétés
je suis sa prochaine partie ce sera 1960
d'après mes calculs avachi sur facebook
[Musique]
l'amd de null null null propose impose
je te le propose pas je te le dis nul tu
as et toc j mais il parle pas de lille
jean non sur toxi sur gary qui lui
imposait à huy il a ressorti un bouquin
il ya questionnaire est de jouer un peu
la jeune homme était un tel livre tel
final allez arrête ça ne m'intéresse pas
c'est parti je ne doute pas je mets donc
genre que le rwanda comme dirait de la
thune aucune culture qui n'y connait
rien ça tout le monde
courant de cette finale devant le sexe
non c'est danser dans le livre de
jet-ski pas je ne ne pas pas lille
numéro trois pages 226 ma finale et là
tu vois là tu ne connais rien aux échecs
alors je ne jouerai plus contre toi
après ça un manque de respect de ne pas
connaître ce cette finale on est parti
vers l'espagnol maintenant
ouais bah katz du coup
voilà deux toi un tour et plus cavalier
minuten par ces 4 ok on va
[Musique]
pourquoi bob bonsoir à sinop 42 bonsoir
à blé oui alors le score le score vous
l'avez juste à côté d'une onde aronian
jeu mettra à partir du prochain russie
5e minute un canidé mieux et vous pouvez
le voir à côté de la tête des joueurs je
mettrai après le 5 + 2 le score de
partout hello hello cac m.harper ouest
et tient du pérou annoncé perd on n'en
sait paieront plus je suis en pls elle
soit s'ils veulent ou non mais c'est
marc perron mais j'ai vraiment pointe et
rouge et je pense au pérou depuis
quelques jours je me sens je me sens
péruvien quelque part un peu de coeur ou
un agent on va te penses tu veuilles est
à tu veux aller la grisonne kaka et tout
ça bah ouais piles et des temples les
machins lettre du moyen et que je peux
pas un truc en plus de bonne cuisine
l'écurie fondée ceviche des machines je
sais c'est que mon père a été très très
hostile aux veaux ceviche girouette au
restaurant c'est pas le faire dès
ceviche ong plus l'âge de faire ça
dégage c'est fantastique
serge envie de faire un plan favori de
fer d'amérique quatre cavaliers des huit
cavaliers six cavaliers à 4 dans
l'esprit afin qu'ils ne sombrent à leur
trouver un nouveau chemin le ramener à
la vie
ce clan bessadi fait rien on ne peut pas
les nuances et 5 non à 5 n'y a rien donc
pas mal de voir mes 36 mhz on a et pis
toi qui est donc bon soir les champions
escale en dessous est ce que pour vous
en dessous de 1600 on est des
sous-hommes ont pour nom en dessous de
2600 et des sous-hommes déjà non qu'on
rajoute 1000 points et toutes façons
vlada dias manière que navarre a été nul
la pression classement 2736 à le prouver
et il a rajouté de toute façon c'est
facile d'être nul n'est tenu
ben sauvelade
j'avais cinq chevaux demandé si on
pouvait pas jouer l'esprit fair c5
d'abord réalisé sur pu reprendre vers
baie saint caprais non c'est un peu un
cadeau d'amour de st un pentagone et
sinon ebadi starts nous avons pas dire
la même si quelqu'un je vole aux échecs
et bien d'autres choses très bien dans
la vie et peu importe
et puis même il a très bien le droit de
ne rien faire bien dans la vie si leurs
yeux ça va faire une sonate indiquerez
faire quelle fin n'est ce pas pourquoi
il faudrait faire quelque chose de bien
en fait fin ça ne se fait pas toi une
bonne personne en fait de bien jouer aux
échecs moi je juge d'autres comme saint
paul est complètement nulle part aux
portes et simple alors c'est mieux
d'être complètement nulle part il être
sympa que d'être hyper compétents de
partout et de ses boîtes celle autour de
soi un peu d'empathie envers les autres
choses c'est cool aussi donc on aborde
donc fait aucun mépris pour les jardins
gavrelle mois s'est vu j'aime pas les
gens qui font les malins qui sont des
messages je déteste vraiment quoi mais
c'est différent quelqu un guide des
bonnes mains jeux peuvent critiquer mais
elles qui sont nuls ne sont pas si nul
ne pas juger même pas les gens le font
les marins intrus pour mon général 1300
mhz et namas en fait aux échecs
réellement comprend tous quasiment rien
en fait
quand un mec serait muller et ce jeu
très complexe quoi donc compris expliqué
se composeront pro comprendre on fait ce
qu'on veut
j'en ai pas spécialement fera que ce
soit toi au moins franchement non enfin
moi je me sens pas du tout fort dans le
sens étaient moins mauvais que d'autres
mais c'est plutôt ça a été moins mauvais
que d'autres mettaient pas spécialement
bon flux je bouge bien fait pièces d'or
alors blizzard va avec lui le shogi plus
complexe que les échecs ou pas en tout
cas pour l'ordinateur whisky a plus de
possibilités au show bis rue cépage est
en jeu
alors junior qu'il n'y en ait un qui
fait trop le malin sur jasmin comme je
sais plus le nom il fait des pls je
croirais mec est un peu plus con que les
autres et celui-là il est très fréquent
que le connaît le même masque
ouais non mais non le masque sais c'est
pas lui c'est quelqu'un dont c'est un
mec masqué qui vient du futur j'ai vu
sur un stream ce mec là mais il avait
alors aussi con que l'autre par contre
ça c'est vrai peut-être même plus
peut-être même plus d'ailleurs il
devrait faire un concours les deux
indices et le respect des autres c'est
ça qui compte
tout à fait
ou le non respect des requis peut aussi
compter sur les gens en pls ça peut ça
peut être aussi
bref c'est un cas laissée par six
calais f5 f 4g 5h kata les fab ont fini
5 + 2 sur une belle partie moi j'attends
le brandon chose doit surtout livrer
échec en fait même garrigues et pour le
rendre au peuple est maintenant trop de
théorie c'est de la merde il l'a dit il
l'a pas dit comme ça donc non paraphrase
dans l'esprit la lys à chaque c'est de
la merde archos est ce qu'il a dit par
l'esprit a dit qu'il n'y arriverait pas
aller trop théorique
j'ai dit ouais j'ai vu le style sursis
avec le mec masqué quoi il est trés
compères tu l'aurais dit dans
l'interview aussi lui c'est vraiment un
sous-homme au nom de fait voulu donner
une piste pour gagner en régularité au
cours d'une partie
si on pouvait le savoir genre tu es très
mauvaise dans un compartiment du jeu
vous tapez pas maintenir la
concentration ou c'est pas le truc et la
fa la vraie l'asu question venir parce
que cette variation juste avant une
opération très super rester concentré
tout le long et qu'elles vont faire
larguer une pièce ou un truc comme ça ça
peut être que juste tu connais rien au
final donc tu as mal d'y jouer enfin je
sais pas ça peut être plein de causes
différentes aussi c'est plutôt
concentration en façonnant il voulait
parler et je ne sais pas on va l'essayer
on va l'essayer
on est comment fait-on pour s'améliorer
avec un livre perso j'ai pas
l'impression progrès c'est le mien c'est
fantastique la sauvegarde de regard
frais l'avoir lu mais est ce que le
givrage
si je ne sais pas où tu parles moi et il
ya aussi des livres de merde enfin
parlons franchement un fabrice ledoux et
des bombes y sommes
non mais un livre pourquoi feint-on le
truc c'est que y'a un truc qui peut être
un peu frustrant échec c'est que tu as
bossé sur le coup ça va pas sans un
marché où le travail ouverture je sais
pas tu y vois je vous devez l'asl avec
les noirs qui bosse à fond je veux
touche attendant les mythologiques et 3g
trois ou quatre g20
non mais tu peux bosser pour rien mais
tu votera jamais pour rien à long terme
livre les heures qui passent dessus à le
faire à le lire at après les dépositions
machin tôt ou tard ça va t'apprendre un
truc quoi le but c'est peut-être pas tu
rejoues parker l'impression que tu as
déjà vu qu'ils ont reçu de la part de la
partie
mais si ça t'apprend des concepts des
trucs au fond ça sera pas si inutile
après celle des livres si c'est vraiment
les nuls
s'il ya des limites effectivement les
des gens qui écrivent des livres on sait
pas pourquoi ça c'est pas mieux jouer
vous des trucs comme ça bizarre
d'efforts mais si tu prends un livre qui
eux il y règne un des chefs de partis
gouvernent en fait je n'aime pas du tout
ce livre je te dire non utilisés ont
entre les mains je n'aime pas du tout si
vous voulez bien
les gens disent qu'il est bien mais je
n'aime pas du tout battue dit classique
tu peux venir le bronstein quoi l'islam
fait rempli caire je sais pas quel est
ton niveau au fronton aussi bahreïn des
fois faut daïra d'ath au niveau janvier
on ne sait pas ton niveau
ouais c'est l'autre bord est ce qui a
fait le manuel de finale de l'épreuve 4
f au prize battez les trois personnes
et aurait peut-être dames 3 f 2000 quand
on prend 1,5 de 9,7 à 9,8
qu'est-ce que succès à l'idée c'est
surtout pour mettre en échec ce cadre
chaque titre b 3 dames ses quatre tours
dame bf cette dame français 5
est ce que tu es ce que c'est si grave
docteur c'est un ton grave le pion à 6
là ça va être graves
mais bon bah le livre de marine si vous
voulez marin vous voulez marine plutôt
me guy romain on est en famille au
legends
ça s'est bien passé sept jours ils nous
faire penser à ça puisqu'il passera
chapitre analyser ce qu'il appelle la
cinquième phase du jeu cerdane tour
comme d'hab' tours à compléter ce mineur
sont fait changer ses pulsions les plus
intéressantes c'est intéressant que la
stratégie de la tactique un peu de tout
mais là ok c'est juste vraiment guéri
pas jo 1 est trop forte
on va tomber il va tomber il est tombé
notorious ont deux points d'écart c'est
quand même bien payé pour n'est point
ouais
mais un tout un débat ce sens sur les
médias sociaux là je sens chaud je te
sens allez je remets un lien pour que
les gens les gens mettent des maîtres
des liens sur les médias sociaux sont
allés après le trou de 2 960 basque jeu
le point d'orgue aujourd'hui très
content ça s'est payé sur assez marrante
il ya des fous de partout 168 à des
pièces complètement vendôme
t'es même pas obligé d'avoir toutes les
mutuelles non mais t'as pas il faut
d'occasions nous est d'avoir quatre
cavaliers tu t'en fous arrêtons fusion
des vrais échecs fabien d'abord loué
mardi j'ai peut-être eu 5 à venir que
pour égaliser à position avec les normes
puisque tu as dame est cloué moi j'ai
très envie de faire grand roque quand
même à un moment donné je trouve que
faire le mandat c'est pourquoi fortement
alors quoi qu'il y eu deux peut-être non
j'aime bien son aprilia pas 3,4 pouces
vais réfléchir parce que même après un
tir au message n'est pas du tout une
grosse erreur le regard dim 11 h théâtre
h4 bon ça boulodrome de 0,5
c'est dans l'esprit fall cinq qualifiés
on s'en fout allez boum boum boum boum
boum boum femmes on y va go go go mais
ils font du counter strike
tu sais go go go go go fava calais
peut-être fou mais trois dates au foot
je sais pas je n'ai pas une promenade
s'arrête c'est un cas tu t'en fou quoi
toi ils préfèrent grands requins emilie
lui ce contrat vient d'être dit bao kg 3
je protège mon cavalier ou je prends et
je fais qualifié 3 arrivera peut-être pu
reprendre car je sais pas j'ai
l'impression que il joue pas mal en fait
l'année pour n'évoquer rapidement même
si toi tu veux garder des options en
fait tu te contre vite au centre et du
coup est ce que c'est vraiment
intéressant de faire grand cas près
demande si tôt par la fête à la retraite
je crois pas non à moitié on met enfin
il les peint mais tout en laissant filer
sport pour être dans le top niveau
taïb ossements l'ouverture tout ça donc
des fois comme ils gagnent régulièrement
il y perd pas son niveau de jeu à
trensacq donc je dois être dangereux
suicide en très bonne forme mais je
pense que petit à petit aperçu plutôt
bien jusque là un certain niveau qu'il
aura toute façon mais je le vois plus
dans le top 10 mondial
je pense à ces filles grâce est fini
pour toi pitot pas toubib tôt pas dans
les mains quand je le voyais à gibraltar
toi tu vas jouer il faisait pas le temps
ultra sérieux le soir digital est subtil
et de vins tranquilles ils allaient pas
juste dormir être à fond enfin ben laden
fatras mon tournoi et qui dans les
premières tables il a été pas là donc la
gueule comme un mets un bouquet on le
sentait étaient là étaient contents il
faisait beau il y avait la mer il faut
les faire 7 qui reste aux fins du procès
la vie quoi voilà libres en mode
destruction massive à l'état match 5 à
l'épisode est allé d'un match 5 rocks
fab
bah je sais pas du tout juste peut dire
à quelque chose ça me paraît trop dans
la chasse à m'exciter trop du coup grand
routes on a l'option de tout ira contre
les options il faudra se décider et
autant à joué-lès-tours nom li
éternellement
bien sûr va commander partie du
championnat de france c'est bien non qui
nous non pas deux ni l'un ni l'autre
n'ont en fait très bien on va on va
faire la coupe du monde femmes on fera
les départage la coupe du monde mais
magnus a dit que ça m'intéressait ça
plus intéressant le championnat de
france derrière la tête ont dénoncé les
gros trucs qu ils remercient me direz
jouer varetz a dit parfois rire tout le
monde
d'ailleurs à mur face à un mur tu as
vers amman
d'ailleurs à rognan il aura attendu
rattraper insolente et roanne on ira
tout le monde et y aura nous pour les
départage et citoyenne on va le demander
mais vous n'avez pas l'argent du coup de
l'office il y aura demandé champagne ans
du coup en faites pas dire trop fait on
fait plein de trucs gratuits serra quand
on atteint guéri ok je n'ai pas la même
personne intelligente peut-être les
tipis des trucs ça c'est cool mais il
n'y a pas un organisateur qui a donné de
l'argent là pour 30 reach de la france
abella tellement rapidement
voilà vous avez des commentaires
officiels mais les gens sont payés sur
place vers nous devons faire des trucs
gratuits enfin bien mais ces derniers
c'est à dire si des fois
donc si jamais vous voulez nous voir
dans ce genre d'événement pire vous
pouvez faire des pétitions quoi ça
tellement vous écrivez sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'elle vous commentaires ont
fait les 2 extreme ce que vous voulez
quoi tout le monde mais en tout cas on
peut pas non et du coup comme comme on
fait du gratuit on se concentre sur les
meilleurs événements mondiaux et donc on
se concentre sur le retour de gary sur
les autres on a des candidats sur les
matchs championnat du monde sur la sinne
que finn cap sur la la coupe du monde a
fortiori mais on le championnat de
france c'est un tournoi assez fort il
n'y a aucun joueur du top 20 mondial
concrètement c'est pas le championnat
des états unis par exemple donc nous on
essaye de se concentrer plus sur le haut
niveau et en plus ya déjà des gens qui
sont payés en plus et déjà les
commentaires qui sont déjà et qui sont
payés pour commenter donc nous on se
concentre sur bakar n'y a pas d'argent
en fait on est là du coup après on va
pas faire on pas commenté jeudi soir
concurrence va reconduire ou non à 20
après sur quoi il y aurait plus de sens
aurait plus de monde qui regarderait
tout ça mais bon on s'en fout ça on
n'est pas là pour on s'en fout enfin
préfère se concentrer sur des trucs
intéressants en fait donc les départage
la coupe du monde 1 fabien c'est
officiel je le ferai en direct tu
viendras quand tu peux dont je peux sûrs
après ce début septembre je peux pas
trop parce que je joue tran tu parles
combien le 2 séparent pendant le premier
tour tu parle d'eux
je riais le 11 juin
bah tu pourras venir tu seras là quand
même pour quelques tours tu seras là
parmi eux du coup je ferai les départage
du premier tour alors est ce que je
ferai des petites annonces ça dépend ça
dépend s'il ya des joueurs français ou
pas aussi mais aucun joueur comme ça
donc on à fraisses etienne est elle
réaliste est bon bien sûr a le mieux
placé paraît loin s'élève près mais les
1/4 finale potentiel contre magnus oui
bon bah pourquoi pas lauzon de
cacahuètes pourquoi pas l'éliminer
pourquoi pas non mais je pense qu'on
aura au moins des partages avec un
joueur français dans le premier tour ou
une tasse ou mur tu as parce que face à
fait quand même quatre joueurs il ya
quand même beaucoup de matches nuls en
coupe du monde
oui sur deux portillons partouche ou non
à une vieille normalement il va se
qualifier facile parce qu'il doit pas
avoir un tour difficile dans les
premiers lots donc ça doit aller on va
être plus facile peu comme le système
fils ou tu un jour un truc millions et
ses rangs le plus fort ou le plus faible
mais en fait je trouve que c'est plus
logique comme si c'est que le système
suisse de wazemmes coupe donc ses
fonctions mais au moins ça protège un
peu la tête de série ben c'est logique
en fait pour peu importe mais mais oui
enfin une position complètement normal
la femme qu'est ce que c'est qu'ils ont
pourri de 960 qu'est ce que c'est que
cette position
non mais neuf cent soixante ans a donné
un peu sur normal je te dis j'ai fait
attendre
c'est plus on a une 6 2007 en espagne
mais j'ai bon boulot kittin contre
contre mon plein de mecs assez forte
il fait chaud que je vois le temps 1 il
était actuellement à léguer une partie
en cinq couples annoncé une couche ce
genre était sur le départ à tavannes à
petit seuls d'attac d'affaires s'arrête
pas vu un truc fois qu'il l'a il est
juste que ce match et j'arrive 4-3-3
france est comme ça travailles tu bref
et est ok en fait google bon tremplin 2
est percé au début c'est un peu
aléatoire mais petit à petit tu vois tu
crains truc là tu développes tu prends
le centre et puis ça ressemble à ça non
mais je sais en fait mais tu as bien
fait de préciser mais après des comptes
vladou quoi les dix équipes pour 960 ses
parts soit l'anarchisme logique et juste
que en arabe de fer que le que les
singes savants on va dire à répéter de
la théorie car des pires auquel quoi
enfin juste ok mais là tu joues là c'est
quand même c'est le skill des échecs qui
parle c'est pas juste n'importe quoi ou
fait tout et n'importe quoi c'est ma
position sans jus aux olives savoir
faire des trucs dame en sciences des
bons films chose en fait c'est juste que
j'avais fait les de la théorie est que
ce soit celui qui est le plus de temps
imparti
chez lui à travailler ou le plus dans
vie qui gagne bah c'est celui qui
apprend le mieux les échecs en fait et
donc toute ta culture africaine en
général
bel et bien vécu ça les décuplé en fait
je pense mais la petite heure
dernièrement parce que toro 3 sur le
casier en france et 5 des 4 donc il
risque de finir injuste - enfin des
opérations non mais tu te bats mais si
c'est que moisins alors quand il a été
dominé à celle souvent un dépôt c'est
une très bonne affaire pour eux mêmes
elle a beaucoup dominé la pendule en
fait née peau et finalement ça mais ça
on s'en doute un nom donc je dirais même
furieusement ce que j'aime bien et à b /
g iii et où est le temps c'est le
problème c'est le problème il a jamais
de temps les vols
mais bon il est en train de se marier
tant ces donneurs jour là quelque part
oui puisque je peux gagner de l'argent
qui est en contre ont boudé cette fausse
kg b 6 ouais et 5 de prêt tu a solidifié
ton truc un marronnier en fait il bouge
bien les y associe candidats plus de
temps n'empêche pas que tout le monde
joue bien les pièces à ce niveau là ah
ah ah
mais paul est un peu écoeuré j'avais 2,8
sur la pendule je me suis précipitée et
il pourrait ajouter que je croirais tu
t'ai connu que le surf projet 3 kg ce
concept pour cette phase 4 en finale
mais pour vous mais la food & 6 pouvez
simplement et il peut de cette affaire
coller les manières d'être très excité
la baisse des cours on né peut il met la
pression et son histoire à la pandémie a
fait une bac il a vraiment l'impression
qu'il ya 2000 compte dix secondes il
alors de réfléchir par higuain bien être
la pression en restant sous pression
incessante en matière on est sous
pression
la de la perdre son sens plus je te dis
je crois que il ya trois coups la sueur
calibre en dessin qui il avait le retire
son projet trois ans peut-être cavaliers
cet échec
oui je te dis mais on s'en fout prostate
faut être quatre en finale
déjà perdu tout les oppose au final je
pense mais tu perds pas quoi travaillent
les banques maintenant il joue plus que
pour ferme une longueur non mais c'est
pas sûr des surfeurs tu comprends
enfermer la tour en as mis du plan que
ça voudrait mais les votes il est
écoeuré là ils en paient à l'érosion
peut-être tour h4 ou tour efficace mais
c'est pas sûr soit merde encore whaou 3
essais je sais ce que j'ai bien joué
c'est le beau jeu c'est le beau jeu
femmes et de jeunes époux il faut le
montrer basse trop vite ne gagnent grâce
aux options pas s'éloigner énorme et
c'est le beau jeu du coup ce qui va se
passer c'est un truc un peu comme ça bah
c'était le beau jeu ça don king hippo
zoobles ouais mais ils font des
minuscules pose généralement fin juste
le temps de mettre des liens en fait
armées - 1 mais c'était c'était sympa
franchement ca et on s'est fait plaisir
cette partie
allez on avait des petits bien là et on
continue à partager de partout ça
partage passer ça partage pas assez
c'est le potentiel de partage n'est pas
tu vois une botte son maximum il ya très
peu de partage ce soir est d'ailleurs la
semaine prochaine j'ai pas encore dire
mais le 31 c'est maxime vachier lagrave
la salle présent il ya que s'ils
partagent fable il ya que s'ils
partagent pls total
lundi six passes en 27
toujours ce débat est construit
davantage des profs at il dit c'est pas
d'interdire les 17 membres non plus
chacun fait ce qu'il veut gagner deux
possibilités de carlos très bon ya pas
de pouce bleus sur twitter ni plus rouge
mis tous rouge mais en fait ya eu 7
pouces rouge sur la vidéo avec mv elle
en fait cette personne est vraiment
temps la camair peyron qui dans ça vaut
le goût de certains clubs ou autres
un or en autodidacte et sur internet bah
écoute tu peux faire les deux fins m
empêche pas l'autre joué en club tu vois
un club sympa où tu as des gens qui vont
progresser et peut-être prendre des
cours mais toi des vrais cours
intéressants comme ça faut voir après
quand ça se passe pourquoi pas que tu
peux faire un peu des tournois a les
joues et tu as des semi rapides le
dimanche que tu as tu fait notre parti
où cette partie sur une journée ça c'est
plutôt cool sans parler d'aller faire
les parties l'on veut sur sur neuf dix
jours après cet intérêt si tu peux aussi
ne baissa constate prendre plus de temps
à dos mais donc tu peux aller dans un
club sans forcément il est tous les
jours non plus et je pourrais en faire
quelques tournois comme ça t'arrange ça
dépend ton niveau se faire accepter
remet ça à gré saint-bauzile jouer en
réel quoi ça peut paraître bien
progresser les parties longues en réel
donc ou a vendu tu peux tester aussi tu
peux nous un club 530 à essence tempo
bien voilà je tâte le terrain culture
mai
mais voilà je rejoindrai sont battus
pour être le faire et travailler en
autodidacte de toute façon il faut le
faire mais c'est dans un club ça ne va
pas tout apprendre que tu travailles
chez toi mars avec et clinicienne
d'échecs avec les livres c'est un de
progresser et pas sûr parler ce que je
dit c'est une c1 mêmes donc voilà faut
pas partir dans un club on va donner une
sorte de recette miracle ou quoi non ça
aide ça n'a pas de chance ça va tout
changer grand chose complètement fait
messaâd ouvrir d'autres
d'autres possibilités de trades et
rencontres de détendre le truc comme ça
alors famille on est combien la sur le
stream on est combien 187 aller il faut
que faut qu'on se batte aller au moins
au moins 200 250 ce soir ça va être un
minimum fabien on peut pas on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas faire mais on ne peut
pas faire moi sinon et nous demandent si
nous ne soient comptés oui fans demain
ben ouais je crois pas de faire
donc rien combes ce match qui serait
intéressant mais il joue tard il jouait
à minuit après marcel en fait entre
minuit et 3 heures du matin heure
française
donc déjà que la voyez on n'a même pas
de sens si on est 17e masters là c'est
un peu un peu dommage
quoi donc donc bon ton de faire des
trucs ou en dépit d'une certaine
influence affluence points
ouais c on préfère se concentrer sur les
matches avec du public quand même un
juste regard d un truc et puis après on
repart repart sur le commentaire ce que
nous ont fait pendant la pause n'a pas
vraiment fait de pause et une petite
fille je vais servir un verre d'eau si
on veut se répartissent espagnol qui
joue sa crise aucune vie un bon stage au
genre du poids études ils ont un très
bon stage il est à faire il ya des
chanceux qui vont le faire
ils sont dans le tchat quelques
personnes plus chanceux que d'autres
donc bas après six autres choses à voir
quelques places il y en a de moins en
moins mais voilà ça moteur si vous
connaissez quelqu'un marty est intéressé
vous pouvez toujours recommandé
éventuellement le stage sera des comptes
rendus de la censure place des petites
vidéos l'ambiance et puis à l'occasion
de ce ramadan faire un seul un suivante
toujours à 25 minutes de pub les
masterclass aussi donc ils vont
reprendre dès septembre mais qui n'ont
jamais arrêté en fait puisque avait des
matches ça peut on les a faits début
août puis la faute aux nantais de pardon
donc donc voilà ça ne vous de son fait
je fais un petit lien pour les master
classes et je vais mettre aussi je vais
je vais aller chercher à fabien leu leu
les scores en fait c'est ça que c'est ça
qu'il faut que je fasse quel score pas
les scores du match pour que les gens
voient bien même s'il est en dessous
d'un bien à cinq années 90 pour à rognan
consent oui oui c'est ça c'est sûr je
vais remettre le temps aussi quelques
petites choses à régler je te laisse le
blé fab
ok donc ce clip de qualité de la part de
dépôts qui se retrouvent donc à être
impulsion pour la qualité donc
normalement c'est pas tout à fait
suffisant mais quand même
mais quand même empathie quatre manches
très affaibli sharon ya donc des
compensations on va mettre un x aussi
c'est un peu une sorte de pieuvre
éventuellement onu avec dame g6 on voit
par là t'as qu'à ce stade ça c'est déjà
la menace rouge and co le cari pareil
sur e4 sa tour en main mon clavier apple
demande qui démarque donc je pensais
quand même d'aider belle compensation
pour la qualité après ça vraiment d'être
l'écrit nord ce qui va faire un truc
comme on veut tous réussis ça serait la
première dépouille était mg6 mais on se
prend déjà qui est relié aux 4
peut-être qu'il peut jouer pour rendre
la qualité ou alors il y aura pour moi
j'entre 25 tours et fuite ensuite c'est
une option mais mais bon ce moulin mieux
pour les marsouins stationnement à bien
bas
ok dames 5 ou pas mal comme en attaque
peu fou et 5 donc ipad ou d'objets
situera juste de me prend fou il fait
foule six échecs 3h suite et maintenant
quoi peut-être tous roumains
ok il était tard d'un match de foot on
doit faire attention à ça mais peut-être
s'infiltrer là bas sinon autre option c
qui a eu quatre ans juste ramener piège
comme orages et inflexions pas forcément
pressés en aucun cas par contre ce
serait murat quand je disais ça c'est
une bonne 4e victoire 4 1 double tête
n'ont pas trouvé tous roland ouvrage
vient la 3g ans
je pense qu'on est bons faveau niveau de
l'écran de cet accord ouais j'ai mis les
scores j'ai mis le chronomètre julia
et sinon là dans le chatt voit qu'ils
demandent si est-ce que c'était
volontaire ou pas de qualité alors je
ferai dimanche je pas le marteau au pire
il ya eu de la chance sur un truc quand
même intéressant beau fils alors d'un
autre un peu pénible de m c'est sûr
d'amener à tour problème de les
tourelles fuite peut-être sais pas si
c'est bien me donner d'échangés ce
matériel mais ça a l'air quand même 2
avec le roi faible de projets trois
syndicats à ouidah proche de 3 encore
plus fort bien vu pas produit de pire
des cas c'est juste le bon coup en fait
mais des fois je me sens très
bienveillants envers moi en fait au pire
des cas rires ça gagne juste sur le
champ mais c'est au pire des cas
beaucoup devient vieux on veut faire
d'objets 6 7 5
et on peut pas faire cavalier 4 qui nous
est proposé à cause de dam des trois
échecs et dames 1re donc des petits
soucis l'année peau du cou touch peuvent
vous faire un nom mais un cinquième
saint paul à temps il se passe à qui il
veut et surtout robin tu veux faire
cavalier f4 en fait j'ai donc genre
d'homme prend dessin il faut garder ce
ton fils après voir un visage aurait
d'abord parce que pas améliorée dame
croix bleue surfe ou quatre il ya
peut-être d'amuser 6 après evian nous
mater en force ce qui menace quand même
un peu sa femme menace pour la thur
sacrifiant f5 mais bon on peut aussi
faire dame prendre des cinq frégates et
des rêves 7 mai il y aura peut-être
cavaliers f4 mec va venir essayer de
nous mater mais ce que je pensais moi
sur fouquet comme ces jeunes dames chez
paou pas changé d'avis même si on y va
pour d'un point d'eau mais mesdames j'ai
six mois ça me faisait peur personne
juste faire d'amis et 8 en fête ou s'en
[ __ ]
face à m c'est pas ça me fait un peu
peur fab familier peur là si j'avais les
noirs facture en pls de niveau 50 avec
tourcoing f4 boom
il vous qu'est ce que c'est que ce
bordel on va mal mater la jordanne des
cinq échecs fougue quatre dames des deux
airois chain de déranger vite même loin
tant pis c'est triste mais on a eu deux
énormes a dit m
c'est ça ce qui leur est mieux rangée de
vrais bons et il ya des gens plus comme
nous on va faire tout réussi un truc
comme ça dégage et la dame et repartir
de l'avant mais je passe et hal gill et
les vidéos sur la chaîne bitstream les
pions c'est de la merde c'est sur
l'arbre de savoir ce que là tu parles du
concept regarde hop tu vas tu avais un
pion devrait déjà y en un qui est
disparu nomme ses geôles a dégagé
l'exception de merde oui mais bon
maintenant il contre mes états d'âme
d'un bizutage et 6 le redoublement c'est
sûr dame sur la méthode mg6 leur tour
retour c'est chaud en fait bachelot
c'est les blancs là qui presse d'alger 6
manar d'un billet je crois deux d'entre
eux ont foutu nommément fermeté à
l'apogée de doha sera tenu au délai pas
le choix face au roi j'ai deux dames ces
deux échecs ou pas rien amené de contre
attaque et maintenant il va falloir
taper b2 parce que la dame protège le
pion à 6 je veux prendre b2 vote des
taux des deux postes kluba si c'est
génial comme partisan et fantastique ce
match en fait un hommage qui si peu de
gens qui le suivent avec nous c'est
d'être dans le pro b de hockey
ouais bah non c'est nouveau les noirs
qui sont devant et peut-être fou et 4
leur retour
va pas faire juste ces trois mois j'ai
juste fait un bon tour et porter
d'assaut c'est parti boum quand même
jour c'est génial part aux espaces amea
fou des cintres bah oui ouais mais
est-ce que c'est grave ça son ouvrage et
8 joue de bonnes choses il a fait
beaucoup d'eux c'est sûr bref c'est
obligatoire c'est forcé 26 mai près il
joue pas il est déconnecté il est
déconnecté il a perdu par la déconnexion
c'est horrible
oh non non à sa femme tu as ça c'est le
seul truc négatif aix en othe way est ok
même bien en fait il est pas content
mais meehan ça le fait chier en fait
d'avoir gagné comme ça là les vannes
mais là ça a pu mettre un coup au moral
à les bonnes femmes cherchant que sata
et 1 là bas non mais je vous regarde
du coup la vidéo renault a pas compris à
quoi que ce soit mais il est de nous
déconnecter
attention attention attention
comprennent de connexion pour les gones
qui pourtant il connaît et on le sent au
sens et il fait des grimaces visent à
regagner les parties du cas de la caméra
ne présente qu'un matin on peut laisser
le temps de se reconnecter ont valu
charge les 30 secondes moi non plus je
pense qu'il faut qu'ils voient un peu de
thé ou un verre de vin bu un verre d'eau
la salle au stress non
là c'est dommage ça dommage ces hommages
bon partie interrompue ça c'est bien
mais on voit qu'il a un problème il a
que deux barres de connexion et surtout
pendulette ses besoins
déjà classé est un problème surtout que
c'était nul à la finale s'était pas
perdre en nombre
même si le gameplay après qu'il a
maintenu des celtic je sais pas quoi
dans nos baskets sont elles pas statique
je pense qu'il y aura bien s'intéresser
en france arrête arrête
gérard toute cette charge était tous les
gens à qui je parle je ne retrouve aucun
supporters de sainté c'est horrible
tayac celle de la rue une personne
l'annoncé de deux noms mais c'est en
dehors de toi les bombers
non mais ok mais bon va prendre ton père
on va prendre toute ta famille fin c'est
forcément il est saint-etienne fait
j'apprends tous tes copains qui habite
saint etienne as et c'est n'importe quoi
enfin bon il ya trois points comme ça
c'est sûr et pour les sceptiques boston
machine je peux pas en manger karpatchev
il est pour west ham
en fait tu peux peut-être pour chaque
fois que tu vas carpates jeu peut-être
le convertir sainte et je pense que ça
lui plairait comme équipe c'est une
petite équipe tout ça il aimerait bien
en fait pas mal d'histoires et tous mes
vrais fous tu parles à karpaty en fait
[Musique]
tag and rich et si vous voulez 250
joueurs ne parlons pas de saintes et a
tout à fait raison là ont fait fuir les
gens mais par contre un pseudo verts
seront sûrement le chat ça me ça me fait
peur mais en fait famille les verts
quelque part mais j'ai un copain à
moscou qui est fan du lokomotiv moscou
et il dit mon coeur est vert comme le
lokomotiv il je suis vermont le sang qui
coule dans mon verre et vous aimez le
sang qui coule dans mes veines dans mes
veines et vers mon coeur hiver aussi de
s'en voir évidemment il est ouvert c'est
un copain qui est sommelier je suis
heureusement tu sors tu sers pas du vin
verres à thé clients mais mon vin les
verts même masse samedi marseille qui
s'écrit mur tu as c'est qui ce type de
mur tu as en fait c'est un mes amis très
proches et c'est un joueur assez connus
puisqu'ils étaient classés au dessus de
1615 pense et il a été champion d'asie
l'échec rapide est en ce moment en tant
qu'entraîneur il est gay quand même il a
quand même été entre l'entraîneur de la
championne du monde moins de 18 ans il
est francophone
en fait ça fait partie vraiment des
meilleurs entraîneurs francophones du
monde en fait un plat demirtas qui
n'entraîne pas en france mais à
l'étranger mais qui font partie des tous
meilleurs spécialistes francophones des
échecs donc voilà des français mais à
mur face mur tu as ton post doc martens
kazakh
mais bon les deux ont vécu en france
pendant de longues semaines vient 10 ans
en son nom peut-être un peu moins
peut-être 5 6 ans 6 ans être bon
validez la verve de 1000 noms dominent
en 2000
ouais mais il est reparti encore en
2007-2008 non hausse voilà quasiment dix
ans il ya partie lorsque sa femme a été
attendu leur petite fille
je sais pas ce qui se passe ça joue pas
je sais pas ce qu'ils font ils sont en
pl en meubles aller vanackere a été
déconnecté ou là on a un à rudolf sur le
souk attention je dois je dois attention
jeu d'enlever une caméra là ou là ou là
je viens ici j'ai vu une éclipse de
soleil quoi moi je pose se dit comme ça
ça la lune est passé devant le soleil
taillard d'ailleurs y ait deux jours les
3 jours touch et heroes ou avant-hier
mais c'est plutôt sur la côte ouest ce
nom là là là complète avec anna anna
rudolf sur le truc que je ne mets pas le
son qu'elle surtout quoi surtout pas
dans des 202 qu'on a franchi la barre
des 200 allez allez on pousse à aller on
souffle vers les 250 300 et chaque si on
était sur youtube on pourrait refaire
400-500 comme un comme un gars une fille
du soleil
attias question intéressante femmes et
pour sainté ça on sait mais tout à kiev
tpour qui toi je pense que tu sais fab
moi je me doute re mais en fait je suis
plus trop le foot depuis longtemps veut
pas vraiment dire chauds supporters
d'une équipe
ouais mais bon je suis plus du tout où
tu vois ce genre j'aime bien l'om mais
enfin comme ça fassi avant je regardais
vraiment les matches et tout ça mais
maintenant ça fait longtemps que je ne
le fais plus je suis plus le rugby en
fait et bizarrement rugby je ne suis
pour personne je suis juste pour les
beaux matchs très bizarre en fait je
peux regarder un match de rugby sans
vraiment être pour une équipe
j'aime bien le jeu de clermont car ils
ont un beau jeu et les jeux c'est pas
comme j'ai vécu pas loin d'oyonnax en
fait je suis très content qui remonte en
top 14 que j'habite ac 30 km à vol
d'oiseau d'oyonnax en fête est donc bon
comme c'est une petite équipe
c'est un peu le synthé du rugby presque
pas non parce qu'ils n'ont pas la même
histoire mais tu vois mais seuls deux
simples clermont même zone géographique
ce panel chose au foot oui oui j'ai
regardé ouais j'ai regardé jeu c'est
vraiment dégoûté parce que ça sympa en
fait le rugby féminin bizarrement très
bizarrement c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant que le football féminin en
fait le rugby féminin c'est assez
intéressant à regarder le foot au
féminin je n'aime pas du tout regardé
samana show qui joue au rugby chine est
menacé c'est un sport très très agréable
à regarder ta bosse qui me change et
surtout quand tu vas marseille en ce
moment je dis ça je dis rien nous
parlons ne parlons pas ne parlons pas de
choses qui fâchent pas ce nom anna
rudolf c'est la femme de l'even non
sinon les choses devraient aller les
vendre à écouler le haut niveau depuis
longtemps la femme de son mari et mes
deux fiancés de l'événement
il va se marier bientôt ils se marient
fin septembre et l'australienne entre
les deux cas au lit très joli très jolie
nana mais on sent fabien que nous a pas
laissé indifférentes mais je vais jouer
contre elle et les rognons devenue la
valise verisk mousseux not not very
small wind fabien non mais c'était cool
mais c'est un type coup de lemon et donc
on parle et de quoi avant que bob dylan
ou pourrir la conversation laïques et
non des rues ni féminin non mais très
agréable parce qu'en fait tu vas cesser
du jeu de mouvement et il ya moins
d'impact il ya plus de tu vois pas ce
que tu vois puis jeu de mouvement
débordement sur les ailes tout ça ouais
mais même tu vois des voiles à des
remises intérieure ont des cadrages
débordements qui ne peut venir d
évitement
non mais si c'est un jeu d'évitement oh
non non on n'a toujours pas la caméra de
devon pas dire qu'on fait au moins s'il
pouvait jouer une cinquième à six il est
revenu il ya sa caméra mais du coup il
faut re caméra il faut que je re caméra
mina non c'est bon ils et cameramen
c'est bon je vais à la manille et plein
écran pour vanessa partie mais on
recommence avec la même hargne et pascal
go qui nous permet rigole entre renier
notre jeu des anglais c'était corps m'a
dit je crois m'être ouest et rhône alpes
il ya 2006 je pense un tueur un papier
dont j'étais pas là donc je peux pas
trop en parler je peux juste auquel j'ai
lu les articles et machin est jamais
trop compris avec des trucs de se battre
avec quelqu'un qui veut qui veut prendre
je n'arrive pas trop à comprendre ainsi
ta copine veut se barrer déjà de base je
suis pas sûr que je sais pas j'ai en
fait je sais pas trop mais j'arrive à 3
comprend ils se sont battus et je sais
qu'ils sont tapés dessus mais après ils
sont revenus avec plusieurs arménien
pour défoncer le maïs a aussi des gens
bien sûr c'est chaud ils sont très
chauds j'aime pas trop ce truc de
revenir à plusieurs pour taper sur un
mec
du coup dans sa partie c'est un peu le
plus souvent des buts alors que les prix
du gazole et en d5 et là il a fini de
changer la structure de production vous
pas joué
comme à roxy mais voilà même chose
ajoutait on hésite et un tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs on avait bien deux joueurs
donc la balle aux us concevoir la
colonne heard on pourra mettre une tour
du front g5 extatique 46 leeuwen a gagné
à la baston je pense qu'il est pas mal
en bas ce temps les bonnes
non non c'est pas un violon mais bon
soin de toi te faire chier
bâle a fortiori bonjour ans sur internet
ça va ça protège ian quelques pas voilà
on sucre
ils agissent ici c'est fou bay josh ici
saute pas très ravier keinon ou du futur
call un petit b 4 pour commencer j'ai
bien arriver là ouais mais faut à 6 la
toile va où
bon alors je veux faire passer sur
prochain je pense qu'ils avaient cette
fois ci ce fait même d'arras is the dome
[Musique]
peut-être fou mais ça pousse et 6 après
menacé c'est le rêve pour le moment j'ai
très envie de faire foulée 5 pouvez
zoomer avec laplaud a [ __ ] son fils
adam sinon on voit cette annonce et 6
mai avec les questions sont trop dominés
lors seraient nominés ce serait mérité
que les vannes il regagne juste après
s'être connecté quand même un fab ouais
parce que oui c'est une défaite un peu
moins je ne devrais pas de regrets à
avoir toujours plus un nombre qui jouait
bruit ni la position de toute façon on
bat pas pour perdre non c'est ça c'est
un peu moche bon mais là on est un peu
plus crevaison contre la montre voilà
remarques ont dit le score ici ça en
plus ils ont mis une partie de hayon
mais en plus il partit de pénalités pour
des connexions parce qu'il était
déconnecté trop longtemps
officiel je crois que c'est ce que
j'étais en train de lire on va voir au
dessus de nous qu'elle grave eric et moi
qui déconne je sois pas sinon je suis né
bogucki eiffage ou des quatre jeux
blancs donne et on repart à égalité mais
ils y ont donné une partie
ça c'est un peu ma chance je pense c'est
complètement indépendantes de sa volonté
ouais mais c'est dans les règles après
les raids sont pourris il faut les
changer
c'est fou cabana ils reprennent à 0 je
sais pas quoi dire ils sont bidons
passant en un an de temps à derrière
avec des ddd vieilles règles et des
règlements toby de subir quoi là tu
crées un truc nouveau tu peux le faire
bien donc je comprends aussi le mec se
déconnecte donc une partie parce qu'il
est perdant il va réclamer les nuls
donne je fais des connectés mais là ça
ok mais tu triches mais farid c'est dans
l'esprit pas y'a déjà il qu'à une maison
qui n'était pas perdre bon déjà il
étudie donc c'est la vie mais non à ben
plus jamais une partie de plus à perdre
pourquoi pas 10 alors ça serait pas mal
qu'on arrive sur les scribes en anglais
parce que là on peut le faire on arrive
c'est très ennuyeux on se fait
complètement biarritz est pas encore
mort enfin plus jamais un stream mais on
gueule c'est vrai qu'ils arrivent yes i
want to say we are all games de penalty
au kaist jens lehmann à ryan rowland
when we seek its own and not not not not
rule l'énergie face à la pression et il
est du coup en fait je vais devenir
insupportable je suis en fait maintenant
pour les vins officiellement déjà
j'étais présent et pour les bonnes mais
préfère les valises avec lui j'ai connu
un peu long et mangeant de cintra
c'était cool est vraiment sympa mais bon
on est pauvre je connais pas le contenu
mais là du coup de la justice suivi on
veut la rendre ta dah
ou alors moi je crois pas ça soit on
veut la remonte à d'assouan et pau et
ultra sport et iran la partie en
abandonnant contre les vannes et du coup
on sera pour un dépôt qui sera sport
parce que ce sera sport de l'avoir fait
donc on sait pas pour qui on est encore
on attend et je perçois tu me rendes la
partie bah oui merci rend pas la mafia
on est contre lui donc c'est à il
l'aurait déjà rendu en tête qu'ils
n'étaient pas au courant ou quoi mais on
va enfin il peut peut-être il le sait
pas encore enfin je sais pas tu as à
jouer mais on peut devenir insupportable
à tout moment là et c'est dommage après
scélérat égard elles ont été écrites
c'est les mêmes pour tout le monde si
c'est elle et si c'était une époque il y
avait une déconnexion afin a fortiori la
même chose arriverait un vespa un truc
continent tire honneur en plus ils
l'aiment bien donc il ya une équité
totale et il va maintenant
bon après dommage pour la connexion
il veut mettre 1 3 et 4 mais bon passons
de l'encoche ce que quand je faisais 4
je n'en savais pas plus facilité à
mateja via la colonne eu en fait en
l'aidant à tous sur 1 re marche 5 qui
moi j'essaie de faire tour à tour mais
il n'empêche ça prend des cinq vit à
tours sète et le massachusetts et
menaces tour des huit tours 17 pour le
moment en tout cas il y aura peut-être
car il ya eu 5 pour empêcher mai
non ça c'est pénible mais la position
même tour des huit maintenant c'est pay
as you go la chanson no 5 ont ces quatre
pas mal aussi
je paye pas et quand tu veux faire quoi
bâton des 8 1 et tours des 8es du
robinet est peut-être tour b8 maintenant
s'activer
non mais là s'il faut surtout pas qu'ils
seront déconnecte ce serait trop
horrible l'agencé pour la déconnexion je
devrais avoir dix minutes en fait le
temps de détente au routeur d'étain son
ordinateur et de redémarrer d'avoir dix
minutes mais des fois j'en de 10 points
moi je sache et quand je prends un orage
ou de dvd montrant quartiers les uns des
deux des conneries comme ça tu fais mais
après tu va forcément avoir une limite
de temps pour que le match puisse puisse
avoir lieu mais ça pourrait être un peu
plus long va dire ça comme ça jusqu'aux
îles d'aix - peut-être tour à trois il
peut pas faire croire france et 4 à
cause de caïds et 6 3
non mais on rencontre tellement la brise
oui c'est vrai il va faire j'ai quatre
il va attaquer comme un malade en fait
me c'est une horreur
c'était parti de la part belle dans
l'est ce matin non mais oui les hommes
et ce à quoi j'ai 5 assez horrible ça
c'est tendance la pénalité juste qu'ils
ont besoin c'est parti non mais la
partie perdue la pénalité s'est passé on
s'affaire dans cette partie là tu viens
tu sais c'est un combo la lassitude joue
à tekken t par terre alat on veut plus
la mecque était fade et des parterres tu
essaies de te relever c'est un robin la
petite balayette là ça m'énervait ça
qu'on l'aimé que tu faisais ça c'est
comme ça il ne te relever tout à
peut-être jamais joué à ça compte google
non mais ok mais était allongé bon le
mec peu plus de taper tu te relèves et
là le mec réussit bien en bon tempo à
trop mettre une petite balayette à de
francs et il te remets par terre c'est
insupportable
red river ici les peaux gagne je casse
tout chez moi et c'est de jargeau
l'assurance tornade nippon torrent
quatre pattes pas d'internet tu perds le
tu perds le match tentant de faire un
tweet non c'est très énervé la wii donc
la forcerie c'est pas nous qui décidons
des règles du speedcast championship
dans son rapport à 9 heures là dedans
elle est bonne il a c'est vrai que les
bonnes il a l'air en pls là sur la
caméra
voilà on sentait si la même plus envie
de jouer là bas elle est là il a l'air
en pls total c'est une arme c'est plus
des échelles du sport qua non à celui
d'histoire mais que oui ce khalifa 65 il
76 il fait toujours penser à millas
khalifa pour les gens qui connaissent
dit ça c'est du cinéma musique et
différents
je pense à amiens khalifa lui qui a pris
un seul fichier radian6 les bons comptes
twitter du sujet bon compte
tu es bien paraître 98 qui dit on va
tous faire un tweet pour faire craquer
de chasse points comme partout sur tous
les réseaux sociaux c'est fantastique on
est tous les jours le chat ça les amis
un califat les gens sont très contents
californien et kelvin confondues et
comment tu venais s'arrête tout le monde
connaît en fait 8 mois c'est le must du
genre de truc ça ta personne qui connaît
la personne que l'on parle déjà comme ça
en face aux twins oui moi aussi je
connais quoi je sais qui c'est passé
c'est sûr que tu en parles pas le
dimanche au dîner de famille quoi est ce
que tu as vu le dernier film là non la
filmographie qui sont moins gratifiant
et moi galsi fait exactement je
cherchais le monde et pourtant pas moins
regardée alors là on se demande pourquoi
non mais ça va pas pour pour les bonnes
âmes est passée juste il va regagner une
relance de la machine
arrivé à
à égalité au moment du machin du du
médecin du bullet et prend jouant comme
quoi mes larmes et oui il sur un bad run
parce que il a perdu de random une
question qui a des idées mal et puis
après un dépôt délire et puis il
s'enferme à la tourte wafa déjà se passe
mal la partie d'avant était de trop
contre la dengue ils ont croqué les
hypers et en plus alors c'est la
déconnexion il la peur mais pour y aller
jamais elles n'ont plus aucune après il
perd la partie sur tapis vert
las il est habile passé grâce à diverses
et 5 points - quoi tapis vert en plus
l'expression là pour le coup marche bien
je le tapis l'échiquier vers effet s'il
a perdu sur l'échiquier fait quand je
lis chic et choc - comme mais alors pas
ici web a toujours ses histoires de
coeur pour la qualité ceci dit je ris
[Musique]
dans les deux pions pour la qualité
c'est être mère un avantage mais en fait
parce qu'on a du mal à attaquer un
vraiment un truc quoi de photos 3d fonds
f2i et par contre sa première rangée et
tempérance d'autres qui est déjà faut
pas la perdre un nul ou bien c'est un
grand homme et non moindre amalgame
dangereux si on prend 1,4 contre france
c'est prendre ces sept ans après c'est
juste trop fort mais c'est sûr qu'on
perd et il voit mal comment empêcher en
fait l'avalanche des pions blancs la
femme ça commence à m'énerver
là je vais devenir hulk moi aussi je
l'aidais vient vers toi aussi tu as fait
ton un brin oui enfin
non mais c'est juste que je vais dire de
faire mon arrivée sur le stream en
anglais enfin à tout moment on peut
arriver c'est ça on est à un clic de 2,2
on peut gueuler
nous on a le pouvoir de gueuler on a le
pouvoir de tweets est donc déjà on re
tweet le match parce que là je sens que
vous
vous vous ne partagiez plus sur les
médias sociaux que certains n'ont pas
pas encore partagé donc on partage de
partout on essaie alors de plus en plus
de vue en france est quand même pareil
quand même important fab c'est les
fondamentaux en quelque part ça les vues
en français bah il en fait si ça se
développe sur deux événements celui
sommes alors s'il ya trop de monde
j'ose dire bon français ça va cinq
minutes on s'en fout et du coup après
ils feront un point ou très peu jarre
peut-être le match de maxime mais c'est
tout alors si si vous avez bien gentil
soirée de ma chaîne est en fait assez
sympa et metouck rapport tout cas c'est
mieux qu'ils du monde pression
aujourd'hui à ces contrats c'est comme
ça mais même pour les autres fois pour
les autres matches les autres qui seront
tenus par maxime de 31 août sur n'est
pas 400 ou 500 franchement fab
il faut qu'il y ait du monde pour maxime
après ce sera avec apple c'est un autre
public sanou public nous avons les
parties restent trop intéressante oui
mais je apparaissent un peu c'est un
commentaire un peu différent oui j'ai
dit non ça reste un frein au public
c'est aussi par manque ce que je sais
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui étaient
mécontents elle en profite pour dire le
le fait d'avoir absolue ça permet
d'intéresser aux échecs d'autres
personnes donc c'est positif pour les
échecs faut pas toujours penser que à
soi
non mais oui ses commentaires plus début
quand on me dirait bien ce que disait ma
part quand on voudrait un débat éclats
sur les convertir deux l'air en fait
genre l'a26 pense que je vénère c'est le
meilleur commentateur en termes d chakim
en fait je pense que c'est la plus
grosse merde qui puisse exister pour
commander des échecs en fait pas dans le
sens que celui d'air et mauvais en fait
pas du tout c'est pas du tout ce qui
veut dire en fait là dessus oui je me
rendis un mec aurait choc et claudine là
bas c'est impossible en fait eux mêmes
un mec à la fin même un mec déjà deux
clubs honnête il va avoir du mal avec
villers wild danse de vente offre ou pas
moi je mets en fait oui non mais toi tu
aimes lire moi aussi j'adore face à
peut-être même aux commentateurs
préférés
d'un point de vue comme ça mais en
dehors de ça je pars là que ses seins
personne ne convainc personne ne
commentera jamais rien comme ça c'est
comme si on parlait de physique
quantique à la télé personne ne va
jamais regarder mais je parle pas la
physique quantique à la alexandre astier
jetés par les flics anti que tu mets tu
mets un mec de physique quantique
quittent eux qui te parles tu veux
parler à d'autres physiciens des
équations partout bah c'est ça auger un
bon ami qui y adopte en physique
quantique
on lui demander d'intervenir sur le
stream c'est intéressant à sa
fantastique
bon on va vendre au mieux des vols - à
faire lourd trois points de retard
attention que gagner celle-là sinon
sinon sinon sinon mais bon il s'entête à
17 23 jeux c'est pas mon à -4 la fable
acide même pas moins 300 points 4 je
crois à tonalité
non c'est moins 3
c'est moins trois par mois j'ai envie
d'aller coller avec la pénalité
les autres via pas eu la bonne idée
selon vous avez peut-être qu'ils n'ont
enlevé j'en sais rien mais j'ai envie de
gueuler toute façon pas de changer la
dynamique du match madr a envie de
gueuler là maintenant c'est fini
non mais je vais écrire un article
demain
enfin les la connexion internet
non les bonnes aronian perd sa connexion
internet ce qui suit est incroyable
alors en fait je vois juste mais qui
perd trois partis ont complètement
annulé la pénalité
ouais on a gueulé allez vas-y femme quoi
on se fait un vrai beau monde a gagné
sauf après avoir regardé le stream en
français daniel règne chez check point
comme décide d'annuler la pénalité
illégale la plus rock
ouais mais bon enfin on respire on
souffle il pourrait y avoir une demande
auprès de auprès du tas de la part de
yade pour dire ouais mais dans les
règlements de rp n'était là dessus du
but sur twitter annulation la pénalité
toutes voiles et les voilà faut lui
faire mal à les premiers placages
premier cadrage débord aller boom bang
et du coup aussi d'attaquer des gens qui
aiment pas spécialement comment on
commente alan vite la pénalité il est
toujours un bon point mais pour revenir
une sortie de là en fait justement silva
son instinct minutes récompensés de nos
échecs et comme on tient bon je peux
marcher je sais pas soit ok c'est pas
bête d'essayer d'autres choses en fait
comme un chien bon là faut toutefois
prendre et 5 et non sur trouville sont
offertes aux progressistes tant chanté
avec le score qui est ce que ton aux six
marches je ferai un enfant chez jeu dans
le premier processeur
excuse-moi femmes j'essaie de recadrer
le score bien aux mêmes qui valide 6 ans
un objet jack et 6,7 mais bon cap si ça
va marcher
non mais les deux sont bons à rien je
sais pas lequel choisir
lille 2 sont très appétissant
peut-être cavale f6 ne bouffe et en
poésie et en compte six sata sas du
procès cette salle permet un massacre en
7 à 14 8 à 14 7 à 4,5 et 4,6 donc l'île
verte en 3 6 3 6 donc il ya une nouvelle
fois une dame de plus j'aime bien bel
adam baies 3 5 et les b777 chine et
qu'ils aient 18 alors peut-être forcée
mais il va se prendre du tour en a
déclenché des jets 4 et 5 mai à vous car
des cas qui dit aux rares 7e rang et
prend même prend 17 cents
ok puis vinrent pions pour tout bouffer
en fait mais je vais lui est prisé
complètement parce qu'être mal autant
alors très sceptique mais en fait je
pense que ces édifices qui est difficile
quand tu joues contenait pour c'est que
le mec trouve toujours des ressources et
même faire c'est vraiment comme dakar un
peu moins fort en fait vraiment bloqué
enfin tu regardes uk les mecs jouent mal
et tout ça et qui en fait je me trouve
plein de ressources comme dit la maman
le mec te sort 30 coups d'ordinateurs
tmz d'affilée enfin pas en blitz mais
dans l'esprit mais tout d'un coup tu
sais pas pourquoi ils jouent tous les
meilleurs coups il comprend tout est
alors qu'il venait de faire de la mer
pendant très longtemps
c'est hyper dur 2001 c'est comme au
tennis les mecs je sais pas comme keira
crachats nafla les nouveaux roscoff le
jeune hemingway mais fognini fâchez pas
et me free plus de 4h alain frachon
c'est le mec avec fin service et son
coup droit monstrueux et parfois sur
sarthon qui l'a injouable et parfois
après je sais pas tu es très loin la
balle et il joue quand même tout le
temps les lignes failli complètement fou
en fait
[Musique]
pas de régularité ok les habitants
commencent à coup et moi cette merde
quelque chose qui a changé
fief de m je pensais juste doublé sur la
première en fait si j'ai quatre sérère
bien tiens dames c'est sain qui veulent
empêcher de doubler bas sur la première
je bosse nous portons grandes écoles ou
instituts vient le tour je joue j'ai
quatre sieverts la tournée même si
c'était des tours atteint leur but de
temps touchart gasconne ils vendent de
la tour e et d'au moins quatre caméras
dame cet échec
non mais du coup là il te fait te laisse
pas gagner comme ça ben il est même deux
mois les français 8
il veut également un réseau que le mcee
chien à sa mémère des gains à
tournefeuille juin
un mot qui est autour d'eux oui autour
de maintenant je pense à toi de mobiles
sur le gpu pour la france dans l'animal
tête h3 reiff 3 dans le même esprit
invoquée mais il est hyper chiant c'est
d'être insupportable à jour en face je
sais pas comment tu fais en fait aux
caisses il est beaucoup plus fort que
nous à rognonas nous on aurait craqué
depuis longtemps mais j'aurais bien aimé
devoir jouer comme un joueur comme né
pauvre femme aurait gueulé tout le temps
en temps je suis gagnon [ __ ] c'est pas
possible c'est encore gagnant le mais
continue à jouer ils trouvent des
ressources et entend peu plus non mais
vrai que la partie s'arrête
la partie s'arrête ya plus de feu sur
qui on comprend pas
j'ai 30
non mais c'est insupportable il joue
vraiment bien et pau la fin il faut
reconnaître
je pense qu'à laisser la chance tu
méprises tu fasses j'arrive juste aidé à
me caler tout est sous contrôle et on
envoie un ouais ça y est voilà allez nom
remonte à la halle et les vents mais je
comprends rien avec la pénalité a très
bien qu'on est d'aider les gens qui sont
plus au courant que nous peut être
j'aimerais bien savoir ce que là pour le
moment
allez allez copains on est reparti on
est reparti on est revenue à 2 points
apparemment donc créatrice a fait dire
qu'ils ont bien porté dans le non bio
porten donc jusqu'alors c'est bien 8,6
malgré le forfait
balas et ouais il ya deux projets car je
pense que j'ai eu un tweet hier 11
minutes de jay scott donc le sitruk
officiel on y met flag
donc elle est tombée le forfait est donc
forfait et un de blender from the
winning positionne vaille et lava runyan
résulte une frigate swing huseynov lâché
6 son pseudo le vampire je sais pas
d'ailleurs une question et vous pouvez
préférer voir
@ lâcher ce disque ou hashtag dépôt pour
regrette de qui on parle juste comme ça
je me demande maintenant c'est quoi la
vente avec djezzy se bouger cette femme
norma alors l'espagnol j'ai
personnellement joseph peyré avec qui le
souhaitent mais ça prend moins nombreux
ce que je dis mais c'est assez à la mode
ce truc un moment je crois que c'est
pour parachuter enfin venu surtout le
dessin qu'il a joués savez sur des six
les blancs jouent soins que juste des 5
soit un peu de benoni féminiser le tout
en riant mais des 5
on est à ce truc de plus raisonner comme
unique notre compte à rebours n'est pas
bon je sais pas lequel est bon on doit
effectivement mais je ne sais pas
hashtag l'ipo frère c'est à dire quoi il
est aidé par tous il aime mieux
n'êtes-vous pas logique aussi aux
quadrilles on va le faire regretter
d'avoir choisi les échecs plutôt que
dota 2 ils sont très mécontents en fait
très très mécontent du forfait de payer
pour rien les dépôts 1 nombreux mais bon
il aurait pu être plus chevaleresque
durant la partie
mais ça en plus il peut le faire assez
j'arrive au tennis ou quoi que des
choses comme ça où tu rends en fait
voiture le point vraiment [ __ ] ceux
des clippers marché c'est déjà arrivé
ou c'est un blessé tu me le ballon
touche durant la touche au gabon
bon qu'est ce que c'est que tout ça
qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde
contents ils doivent à chaque partie non
madame là c'est n'importe quoi la gata
normes isa qui prend fou prend roi suite
qui est son idée pour prendre de 9 6
pour la grippe total foot français sans
intermédiaire mais alors pourquoi qu'est
ce qu'on veut sur ton problème
je comprends pas pourquoi je comprends
rien de très brillant ok je sors n'est
plus aux pressions possibles d'un v6 bon
là basilea oui mais qu'est ce que vous
faites là ici et que j'essaie de 4 ans 3
4 des 5 et des chiens qui a eu 4 ou un
truc je sais pas alors que la bombarde
interpelle mais bon en fait ça ne remet
pour l'époque ça sachez pas assez bien
pour les jours prochains mais je
comprends pas c'est juste gagner en fait
non mais bon pas sans quelques deux
choux commercial de foot on s'est quand
même beaucoup n'ont pas fait retour des
8 faut cinq dames cette fuite on prend
17 et tu peux pas prendre la lame ce
qu'ils remettent du coup 1 200
mais aucun pli un petit kata variante
surtout aux 5 davos à tfo des six mais
je peux faire dame prend des six tours
prend comprend les hoquets par dingue de
six bons principes
je comprends rien chanvre des recettes
marchait pas et f6 medamos est séparée
c'est juste beaucoup mieux avec cette
année peut-être fou j'ai cet échec faut
le montrer c'est avec ce jeu jusqu'à 200
m tous les matchs du couloir tous les
machins chion dire que maintenant tu
mets 06 par les banques ont menacé
gbagbo de ces dames prend tour et les
maths du couloir et lâcheté être en fait
non c'est simplement gagnant pour les
plans sa personne ouais mais montre
aussi ce toit au système prend 1,6 ouais
mais on reprendre en janvier d'une motte
même après 3,7 et la finale est quand
même dur à gagner puisque temps fou et
bloquer les pions sont fous et des biens
au moins d'élus faire trop c'est son
prochain jeu sur je prends soin et je
pense que red de chez red
d'ailleurs marc rares matériel y at war
de choquant windham c'est beaucoup quoi
et activités des pièces machin moi j'ai
vu de fait je pense qu'il devait faire
avant pour pouvoir jouer avec tam prend
aussi ces machins ah oui mais nathan
lawson
je veux une pièce juste entourent prend
2,8 à huy avait d'apprendre était un
grand tour pardon mais tu comprends rien
fait pourquoi est ce qu'il à fait fou et
sabu s'est pas claqué en fait on se dit
plus laval est la juste d'arriver
ces six mois je vais bien bon ça relève
ayant pour le vent mais bon on ne jurera
plus de rien cet article 5
tu as toujours être sur la 8e cette
recette intel d'amd 5,2 me dit quelque
chose ce sont des cinq pas mal je me
trompe ou de nouveau à ces méga science
a là c'est fini
donc re +3 du rhin
dur fab mais en fait j'ai eu pas mal
d'heures dans cette partie des deux
chauffards la partie était hyper ressort
à l'avoir au ralenti mais je pense qu'il
ya plusieurs gaffes de parts et d'autres
prague est mobile ce concept si
compliqué que ça c'est normal pizza ce
week-end plusieurs jeux là vous êtes
très épuisant
il ya toujours un peu l'intrus qui
venait touche ni des six dessins qu'il
en a marre sont souvent à marbella tout
le monde veut revoir la remonte à la
rogne and look et j'aurais bien aimé
garder les dalhemois faut faire si
j'avais fuji cas tout ce manager je sais
pas faut dire que tranquille mais je
pense qu'il est dans le dans le dur la
sq logiquement je pense que là il y là
il a lâché dans la tête
bah oui dont six nations non mais tu le
sors fait c'est chiant nom est à dire un
peu comme c'est un peu comme fait des
comptes nadal auquel nadal forcément il
va jamais lâché à miss france il va
jamais venu shalash à 100% mentalement
c'est juste que si nadal est enfin
fédéral s'était pas nadal en face ils
remontent géré par là que là il est
quand même dans les taux d'à ronia de
données pour il est dans son réseau dans
le sens où l'otage quand il joue ses
positions compliquées il sacrifie de
partout et j'aime toutes les lignes
arrive plus trop en fait
ok je recueille aussi 6 6 3 6 4 pour le
secteur des titres ou des 5 pour être un
de ceux ci un mélange entre combat
douteux four b3 tu nas de l'enfermer qui
accueille donc peut-être là pas de
tomber deux bons après l'énorme comme
étant sorti l'équipe est le théâtre de
s'y faire fou prend un cavalier des cinq
dans la qualité sans nom c'était
peut-être un peu bizarre mais f4 ok
autre tentative joue contre le cavalier
vite de 8 i te dis toi tu bougera plus
évoqué cet espace vert
alors foutez sympa donc les gens vont et
qui le 3 l'histoire tour des 3 et
reprendre le 5ème tour d2 et reprend 1,5
avec le carré des ventes des six ou sept
places non plus l'appareil
peut-être qu'à aider 5 tous les membres
[Musique]
ont fait une fois une décision puisque
l'idée qu'a eue des six est bien jouer
tu laisses leurs clients on croit que ça
jusque là on avait vu mais elle qui a
été si c'est bien joué en fait est bon
on put rachid peut être un peu embêtant
certaines variantes
c'est pas en train de vous gaver
soutiennent l'un l'autre
joe pajer comme en profite ce roi noir
auquel est en semi réseau là bas
quelques pions h67 shopping mais il ya
tout à fait pas tout stressé de lâcher
nord est bon pion à fond sylvanus quant
à 3 ce jeu avec afftac
tadjau f5 f5 food et saint cloud et 5 en
premier elle 5 et après tu veux prendra
effet danger si ce faire tu vois là tu
as quand même un peu court et le
cavalier ces quatre là tu fais f5
d'envoi est l'objet de pressions
maintenant mes tarifs 5 et le mec ne
fais pas ce que je dis aussi c'est bon
signe attention à tours 1 kg 4
fourchette un extrait tricherie perche 1
comme on dit ce n'est pas oui
heureusement qui est pas si fort en
langue serait un peu insupportable
montreuil swan et s'imprégner - qui est
j 4 1 6 c'est un peu de problèmes c'est
cette image in bon ok on se reprend du
jeu celui-ci se saisisse
bon attention pour prendre cette menace
non il veut avoir tout repris f5 les
rentrées final nul fanu peut-être nul
mais ça doit aller quand même elle doit
tenir la finale de pions après tourcoing
16.7 quadrant f5 prise crise prison pour
af c'est t on à l'activité du roi
attaque déjà les pions des questions
ouvertes et d'angélique qui atteint 3
arrivées suffit que tu feras f4 ici je
vais faire bref khadir experts notre
famille kg et canal l'ex
non mais peut-être c'est pas si grave
leroy peut-être bien placés en c3
puisque surpassant le 5 avec un crayon
c3 il sera à tort à la tour c 7 en
diagonale par rapport aux trucs et le
roi c3 aussi roi c'est froid ici qui
disent ils ont tourné autour des trois
firmes épouse bien vu tourner trois de
cinq secondes bac 4 5 avec paris vii
c'est nul d'écrans plats et aux enfants
eux et ne bon mais par rapport à la
position qu'on ait eu à entendre et
c'est plutôt bien eu beau
je ne comprends pas comment les jeunes
peut revenir en bullet franchement vu la
neige exécution de ce niveau alors le
gars du match jouera contre qu'il va
falloir regarder le tableau je sais pas
si tu as le tableau sous les yeux moi
j'ai pas le tableau sous les yeux je
peux te dire ça en fait attend juste
devant comme enjeu de taille sur vidéo
échecs fide chasse championship en fait
ouais je vais copier l'article notre
étude les vins a joué l'année dernière
elle avait perdu contre gritche aucun
match fera qu'augmenter avec vlad un
match qui s'était joué à milan les
bélarusses
alors on lui contre le vainqueur du
quart yakine meilleur donc contrecarrer
la quille mes carnets qu'il n'est pas ça
pourrait être sympa comme match derrière
lui en fait tous les ballons à mozilla
que des matchs sympas quoi toute façon
une grosse compétition
il est ouvert jambreks affronte système
de coupe ce qu'on trouve ça sympa c'est
bien pâle on est content de cette
position qu'après juste la banque
on n'était pas content l'histoire de la
déconnexion ça c'est pénible deuxième
tour 12 octobre 19 octobre au 2 novembre
9 novembre
sas les dates sont restés normalement
attention car il ya de la fab 1 les gens
toujours du chocolat chine attention qui
avait dit à 2
ouais ouais ouais il fait là bas les
ticos version des trois mêmes qu'elle
est et centre x42 droits de l'homme
sorti un jeu passe super inquiétante
il veut faire fait tour à quai ce qui
est peut-être fait retour à 4 en plus
cela nous avons surtout rhin je pense on
veut faire le 4 puis il faut ici ou là
il était temps d un monde qui nous
regarde avec mon prisonniers mais
pourquoi pas fou et fils maintenant
peut-être encore un cas tu as km2 chope
et puis on sait qu'à sympa ça si tu es
et quatre chocs tout je ressens par ses
trois as les novices de khat est
maintenant tombé ouais bof 6 maintenant
sur le 4-4 ou six
en plus sur foot ok moi pour faire
[ __ ] en est tout reprend ses quatre
pattes le siam a du coup la balle orange
sfr affiche quant à lui je voulais me
dès lors cette semaine du couloir est
condamnable et on pense que 4 je pense
même si tu as un quatre contre trois et
c'est pas obligatoirement gagnant mais
bon ok on a des pièces où on va il veut
tu as joué cavalier ab4 en premier vous
menacez mat au passage alors à temps et
ce qui me laisse quelque chose de joli
mais reste peut-être prise en âge 6 ok
vous bougez de chou quoi ces trois
tireuses 7
ouais probable de sa branche issue du
des trucs intervenez en mieux mais avec
un peu arrangé mais répondre aux menaces
skype rights watch qui se fout quoi ces
trois autres têtes rouges et 5 en fait
c'est pareil difficile jeu pour gagner
en fait ici
piège manche quand même la zone piquée
b4
sur une peau de banane faisaient
6 alors c'est pas ça valait 1 2 5 et 3
ok les russes à castres on ne pouvait
pas prendre l'option bresse qu'on n'a
pas saisi sa jours mais moi qui ai dit
bon on en a quatre
un musée si jamais jean ans il fout le
bordel tout temps mais pour faire qu'un
truc dans les justes de jeu technique
rame était pièce est dit de laisser
faire comme ça quoi
et bizarrement fait beaucoup plus
accrocheurs là n'est bon coeur en
langues
en fait ce qu'ils voteront oui dont il
est mal ils lâchent la partie hays temps
ces peaux de bananes par ci par là mais
j'étais trop grotesque en gros en n'a en
fait fait la même chose en long mais
c'est juste quand on s'est tellement
grotesque que ça marche pas mais nos
hôpitaux
bon déjà il va s'en sortir on a un truc
comme m6 ne changeait de saint guy
vassal
il veut surprise me elle est peut-être
quand même faire f 5 premiers premier
succès on a quand même progressé avec
les noirs et là 4 contre 3 surtout
retour des six vous prend 1,3 je suis
pas sûr qu'elle soit nul 1 1 ce qui va
avoir la tour qui arrive en c2 leroy qui
vaille en germes alsace je pense d'eux
gagne il ya peut-être un chemin pour le
roi vierge et 4 et si l'on arrive à
angers 4 ce serait bon mais je mets une
tour ces deux échecs ça me paraissait je
comprends pas 26 jose coupe et la
sixième de rang
clairoix ils'agit 80 on peut faire f 4
je pense pas mais ça pourrait dans
l'esprit
mais l'idée surtout en d6
le jour au québec 3 6
c'est toujours quelque part ton dessin
une fin très caisse est obligé de faire
tomber 5 quelque chose comme ça mais tu
vas avoir des problèmes que le pion aux
cas tu vas pouvoir tout faire puisque
jean retour bessin qui va te faire puis
on prend un f5 sur ferme devant et va te
faire tourner
non mais il va peut-être commencer par
moi ya peut-être des tourelles froid
encore qui se bat bien là faut qu'ils
nous les vendent surtout pas tomber
bah oui parce que c'est sa direction que
j'avais sept ou huit heures et trois
sets mais c'est nul ça
j'ai parvenir nous vous donnerons des
échecs car jouer ici c'est tout réussi
et si c'est tout mais bon même tout
réussi s'ajoute au final leur hausse au
2e tour prend ra prend 3 f k 3 des 5 3
et 5 trébuché et vautours francs roi
prend way atterrissent reprend 1,4 j-6
bout froide et 5 chez pas penser à ces
niveaux il a peut-être raison ne pas
chercher
bon ça c'est nul en sept finales à tours
oui
oui jamais passé in on est un peu
décevant cette partie on n'était pas
forcément loin de de la gagne il a bien
poussé mais qui arrange sans silicone
qui demande sur le chat en anglais ce
qu'il essaye de gagner de perdre cette
partie pas exagérer il a tenté le tout
pour le tout mais bon trop juste la zone
tampon non non il a bien tenté mais bien
joué de la part de core i7 960 j'ai dû
avoir le mauvais timing qui ne trompe rs
avec le timing alors une nouvelle
position tient une nouvelle fois un peu
rauque et des deux côtés
il y aura trois minutes de pause après
cette partie avant de démarrer les
bullet man ma femme on est dans le dur
j'y crois encore fab
j'y crois encore en bullet tout peut
arriver
on a déjà vu des choses très étonnante
arrive en bullet j'y crois encore je
sais pas ce que les gens pensent dans le
chat à l'est qui est là les hashtags
#tsunami and #sendai peau allez dites
nous un petit peu vous êtes vous êtes de
quel côté qu'est ce que vous en pensez
allez le chat on nous donne un peu son
point de vue et les tours pour eu six
cavaliers g5
allez on sacrifie de partout va pourquoi
pas drôle juste devant les mini pousses
ont fouillé très vite en face au nahd du
team à rognac et ultime n'est peau est
ce qu'on va remonter les mecs
est ce que le team dépôts va tenir est
ce que le team aronian va remonter assez
partagés dans le chas est partagé à les
poupées deux fous ces trois dames d2 à
l'efa bon on se bat de partout des
défauts de la position c'est la donne
enfin la dame de chacun la femme c'est
que c'est des points qui va se sentir
sodome et donc c'est pas 2 5gt pas fan
tu affirmes keita qui dit tim libye mais
libye attention attention libye tu n'es
tu n'es tu ne joues pas est ce que tu
penses qu'avec un handicap de 10 points
tubes années peau en format de beats et
championship
oui mon gars seront lancés
j'ai peur que même avec 10 points
les fab on se bat non mesdames des trois
fois trois grands rocha les femmes
personne
on respire un peu mais bon sens même pas
hyper ravi parce qu'on n'a même pas
d'énormes attaques contre le roi des
allées dam des trois années boum je
pense mais on n'aura jamais front des
changes des dames et qui en fait une
finale je sais pas fou à 3 ans 1er allez
vous ça pour détroit l'invoquer mesdames
detroit on aurait peut-être cavaliers f3
je ne sais pas dames f3 pour échanger
avant on s'accroche
allez on avait 10 nov allez accroche toi
on sort des rockets ont c'est dur c'est
dur c'est bien on remarque des rockeurs
de rackham le rouge ces deux femmes ça
va ça va c'est vite dit quoi alors on a
joué des grottes fab un joueur deux
coups un peu mais je sais pas mais ok
roi c'est un roi b2 dans l'esprit de la
drogue tue amina monde de revenir au
rythme le problème c'est le flou surtout
maintenant la touche on faisait mal et
l'harmonie c'est ses défauts et chaque
fable 2 voilà il ya ya ya ya goldorak
il nous dit voilà g4 g5 mange mais qui
ont les plombs c'est de la merde voilà
ça voilà ça c'est bien d'y aller car il
prend à 5 ans pousse le pion à comme des
malades aller
dam des dames d un fameux j'aime bien
d'amener un jeu forcé changé d'âme même
peut-être d'un f2 à les fab
malheureusement je suis là pour te pour
te repousser la pas parce que tu me bats
ta à la tête dans le seau là ouais je
peux aller vers le nord et l
épanouissement des faibles moyens et
qu'on pousse à damas les rites allez
vous on échange
pouget ce qu'est ce qui va lier pousse
le bouchon un fonds comme c'est ça on va
mettre le car a lancé six on va pousser
comme des débiles c'est général brassard
noir des cinq tours 18 soit on a
toujours un but à la fin et on n'en voit
plus aller comme sur des roulettes 20e à
les tracés dames en fait on est bien là
ouais je sais pas comment ça tourne rond
tant mieux le bail mais bon enfin c'est
déjà faire c'est l'énergie quoi on y va
c'est l'arrivée du championnat dans le
chat en fait servi de chair dans le chat
qui veut nous balancer des quatre on
s'en fout non mais ce qu'il veut nous
faire remarquer ici si je cherche des
quatre champions prend puis on prend
genre on s'en fout toujours en phase 1
qui fait il fait des trois jours il veut
faire payer feront à coup je tourne je
m'attends médias c'est chiant mais nous
faire des trucs comme ça n'arrêtait pas
mal de trucs contre eux dans un truc
tout à l'air aussi choisi un canard une
finale tu as ton plus ou moins bien
passé et les pièces un peu partout donc
là ok pour un coût de l'e3 on peut se
faire soit nous mêmes c'est parce que ça
va soit se fait par mois ces deux très
grosses par mois c'est du livre est donc
loin d'être nouvelle et de nous faire
quelques trois autres comme cette frappe
sion prend le cas les pros puis on prend
un tour à deux c'est du tai chi
c'est du tai chi c'est du tai-chi
regarde viendront de notre jeu et on
prend c'est pas grave
trois des deux voire trois oui ok on va
pousser fonds ni vais tenter des trucs
comme ça qu'on le voit venir juste
d'être fait président en fait il dit
quoi à les brader de tonton voix des
deux taureaux 3 pts aura changé cet
entourage croirait tais toi je crois à 5
sur rodez 2 que je veux faire tourcoing
h deux tours à chaud et le froid ces
ingrats b2t changer toutes allées
cavalières cinq cavaliers 5 quand on
voit la traite raid
très très bien fonctionné ans il prend
prend à 5 b43 mettront à ses 4 c'est
fini sont en voie c'est la voix trop
forte
nice est bon là c'est bon la fab a5b 4
ça arrivera mais trois c4 si on ferra 5
bêta 3 fêtera ses 15 ans et demi tombé à
-2 ses bulles est dite frappée
non mon frappe directe en fait en bullet
butin ils trouvent toujours des coups
booba ceinture 1re cat assisteront au 5
à 7 un os qui valait 1 tour 8
ça fait film machin et ils voient ils
sont fous qui tente d'obtenir des pions
ce qui doit perdre mais mais pas comme
ça c'est bon c'est bon cavalier va
peut-être venir mais moins bien joué
mais on bouge mais melty on sur a7 et
bien c'est bien toi
après c'est peu énervé comme nous c'est
bien d'eux à les rois p33 donc là ok
j'ai vraiment ok si sûrement plus
gagnante aux grecs on sait qu'avec avait
quatre bien joué en cariste à cet égard
il ya deux mois ci c'est quand des deux
roues 3,2 car ici c'est donc allé d'une
partie quoi gagner une partie in y aller
on a moins de on est là on est on est à
fond on mènera leone mais on met le
on fait en fait les médias sociaux après
je mange un tout petit trou en deux
minutes et je suis là on est sur les
réseaux sociaux fab aller les réseaux
sociaux de partout
jean son parti une minute pour se
rafraîchir
seulement deux points d'écart avant les
bullet entre aronian est né pauvre donc
ça c'est envoyé
et on va mettre aussi là je vous
remettre le lien à partager de partout
où je sais pas si on en restera encore
deux sens et ce qu'on est encore plus
même presque le centre cent quatre vingt
dix
allez c'est pas énorme une bête on ce
bot mon peu après peut-être plus de gens
qui regardent ensemble ce soir et cajun
et peut-être des personnes qui sont du
coup en groupe 1 c'est pas sûr qu'ils
aient moins de monde qui regarde en fait
en réalité
peut-être un micron gérin lajoie sur la
place la place centrale pour suri non
julien qui s'est séparé pour kippour qui
pour qui être ils étaient deux joueurs
sont très sympas tu peux être pour les
deux en même temps
oui pour le beau jeu pour le beau jurer
absenté une paix qui finit de faire des
heureux
ok ok donc là on les voit se remettre en
place sur les images sais pas combien de
temps dure la pause en fait mais je
commence à pas trop trop tarder donc
c'est nous dit sur le chat soja le
hashtag neutre voilà tu parles hashtags
suisse si tu veux
bon ok t'es pas donner des trucs sur le
chat si vous voulez juste avant que ces
petites bulles est way résident de dire
et qui aurait enlevé la finalité
maastricht ça peut se jouer là dessus
comme si un et deux points d'écart c'est
vrai que 1
mais après en même temps on budget
on sent et pau favoris et ma mère c'est
parti drogba du budget de pure puisqu'il
ya une seconde de rajouts mais quand
même quand même ça va aller vite
maintenant qu'elle nous rejoue la
variante d'espagnol detroit qui ont déjà
joué un peu n'importe quel prados t4
alors préparé pour ce match en fait née
peau et aux caisses leur position n'ont
toujours comme d'hab les noirs ils ont
un peu de mauvais fou aux stats
donc on va arriver à s'en débarrasser et
vos soeurs et qu'il est est aussi qui
aimait cette qui fait pas grand chose
mais j'ai lu cette manoeuvre est passé
par des 8 ce qui est en train de nous
faire pour revenir vers eux aussi c'est
donc avec des cases et qui a pris quatre
peut-être chose comme ça donc j'ai un
fonds que doit aller pour les noirs mais
niveau est bien là dedans qui s'est déjà
chauffé en jouer avant le match ça peut
être intéressant pour une particule être
mais au moins à rognan comme il a été
confronté à ça dans les parties de blitz
avant noté naturellement il a trouvé le
bon plan est donc bien parti pour f 5 1
pas mal qu'il faut le 5
si on pouvait pas reprendre ses cahiers
le 6 l'année adam donc du coup sa
deuxième version
mais bon pacini ainsi des bulles est
souvent un peu le jeu on verra je me
trouvais pas laisser traîner
ok t'es retrouvé occasion de plus pour
des pommes avec a planté un petit
tactique et kibaki kahn beaucoup mieux
ces cavaliers
même cinq phases est puni et b5 j'ai pas
tout compris du même style et à bab
latour statique soirée colonnes mais bon
au moins ça nous agace t 5 fixe quand
même aussi pioncer cet état plus et si
ça ne s'est pas ça sent quand même
mauvais un noyau b qui ont séché à tour
kikwit soit troisième rangée l'adhan en
d4 ou quoi l'écrasement là bas tu peux
te retrouverai schéma de matt hill tout
reprend 1,4 il peut arriver un jour je
sais pas peut être tout à fait crossfit
11.4 où je sais pas un truc comme ça
c'est clair que c'est bernard
normalement mais bon c'est du bullet
train tu peut t'arriver encore le taux
refi strauss mais là c'est chiant je
sais pas moi je rentre ou je te fais un
tour j'ai trois passes quand justin sur
tanger 700 g iii vous vous bouffe ya pas
de damien n'y a pas de machin quoi tu
contrôles tout ça vient de gagner leurs
saillies rentrer dans la grotte et
higuain ok cette partie de ne pas bon
signe pour la suite du match comme les
peaux très impressionnant jeu très vite
et david renard pour la tactique a
traîné de la planter et ils ont dit aux
friteries plus proche pour 2,5 kg à vide
souvenez-vous ça tourne donc pire qu'au
paris x oui objectif c'est ci-dessous g4
on a déjà vu ça dans le match vous
prennent trois caisses baril va faire
c'est si ça traîne voyons pas grand
chose pour le moment
barroso de neuf sous le soleil de tous
qui souffre c'est ça qui est en jeu mais
plus de cases mais bon il ya le foot est
roi qui rayonne donc et d'endormir vis
de calais on penserait pas de découverte
totale j'ai reçu b6 obligé
et un autre bien défendre on casse les
pièces
bon les blondes de tenter un truc à
quelque 4 un moment d'un match 4 et
partir à la tête la wax qui va faire
très bientôt non ils essayent de régler
un peu les problèmes
elle donne ménéz paul laisse jamais
faire toujours toujours chien ni
tournant contre jeu dans l'activité
péniblement d'un but ce genre vous un
peu comme maxime a des potes
ouais mais un peu moins dans ce style là
mais c'est quand même un peu ça ils
s'activent tout le temps anaqua aussi kg
c'est aussi un petit pic dans l'ue
belgique ouakam le client le 5 et les
libyennes utile aussi tient à castétis
les blancs devra bien les plantes
accueilli la barre en très petit à petit
sur pied long la carcasse et 6 des
quatre derniers 6,5 brûlé tour qui est
passionnant ça va être cool donc sur
sané pour jouer à fond de partout où ils
placent bien ses cavaliers ils jouent
chaissac l5 donc occupe de tout
recommencer si j'imagine b4 bon c'est un
endroit très bien pour les lans position
mais bon père de tous à quelle vitesse
il est vu se replacer sur le roi
fantastique en fait mais bon le fond u15
effet le fond à 5 avec le pion c7 ces
foires pareillement femmes
bon ok soit la nature se faire attaquer
jaro t il il a donn tour vous me
demandez bien
elle soutient la dame qui peut coulisser
vers bessette maintenant pour aller
choper armavir gagner je pense qu il ait
mis autant les arrivants c'est comme ça
tout le temps mais moi j'ai deux
peut-être que je serai bien mb cette
personne
bon alors qu'angers trois de nos plantes
et un père peut être pour ça jdo junior
hockey étaient toutes leurs petites
minutes entre m
je ne sais pas un moquer mais [ __ ] sa
pensée ça c'est de faire rager deux
sujets pour gagner mais bon même et
c'est dommage je dois faire coude à mons
je suis pressée perpète fister pire ou
mieux mais c'était pire oui ok tournoi
second bon ce que dom vayssette machine
tient là non mais attends il tient tête
tous là peut-être ces huit dames à
yan'an 22,3 au h2s
perpète point cette émission dans mes
temps étaient inquiets à l'idée d'être
eu que des échecs partout aussi il a
plus de temps vous ces trois mois il va
tomber il va tomber il va tomber dans
meilleures ajoute dame prend finissent
pas fini on prend des 6000 mah tomber il
va tomber bâton mais non prime ou
d'autres échecs ça va avec des trophées
elle est en train de saint damase trois
quarts venir couvrir les chefs des
missions étaient sur le pont ce puisqu à
d'halo 2 oui oui malgré le mahou sipec
dame de il énervé 1
il est hyper énervé sur la caméra les
vols il est hyper énerver encore là mais
mon espagnol ou quoi portent la burqa
mais je pense qu'après le maroussi
pleurer quand même puis abandonnée en
étant quand même perdant bon après c'est
dans le wagon se trouvait internet une
souris ça entre en jeu la vision de d
une connerie comme ça que je crois si tu
ne prends pas fou projetteront temps
normal
c'est assez flagrant break sur un ace ça
va plus vite aussi sur un échiquier ces
choses là tu peux jouer avec moins de
temps sur sur internet dans les nouveaux
à moins 2 ouais ça pourrait coller seule
la non il est bon et que 401 que le
petit vus les textos les veaux n'ya non
mais qui l'armée russe c'est plutôt un
yann quoi et enfin comme à rosny abelsys
aznavour yann par exemple s'ils allaient
les tontons on est dans le jeu on est
encore dedans code 3,7 j-6 je sais pas
si diby qui nous façonne ses merdes à
disposition objectivement pas autrement
bien et son premier trophée à cinq qui
sont le besoin c'est un peu dur est fait
ce que tombe il est logique quoi tout
arrive t'on pur hariri ouais bon
qu'est-ce qui nous fait maintenant des
juges sur quoi les dames les trois des
cinq postes on s'en fout qu'il s'agisse
de nouveau ses atours assad j'aime bien
ouais mais bon oeil la proposition de la
seule que nous verte c'est un peu
pénible en c1 dames de tours j'ai trois
un peu de partout
peut-être faire tousser 8 pour essayer
d'échanger une tour me permettra d'avoir
des problèmes sur serre en fait même et
il fait tour ici en premier trois sets
vos visites g7 où il est moins bien on
est déjà moins bien au ghana soit enfin
cette norme puisqu'il ya tout ce qu'on
leur fasse pas bien principalement un
problème d'homme et gîtes sont bons pour
changer là je pense que tout est changé
ça met du bouquet de votre annonce si tu
as fait un projet 3 qui les projets 3.4
il faiblesse partout campion d ici ce
machin qu'elle est très très fort mais
absente sur cavaliers preuve la f5 pour
le poisson ok peut-être une chance avec
notre pion à 4 ou pour ces deux
démarches h 30 dessin peut faire pour
ces deux est allé faire un bep jeu et
puis ce processus comme aux flashs en
sauveur tu aurais pas fait échec en
premier personne ce que le pur est venu
en fait on s'en fout je pense mais bon
il a voulu éviter roi et faroy machin
cette mort prend un peu ce soir on est
moins bien pas son beauf v2 de puteaux
l'homme non mais si on prend b2 s'est
passé que je ne comprenais pas attendre
qu'est ce que c'est ça la marine
française partait fille obtient non mais
jo à sotchi [ __ ] la réponse à gérer ça
pousse pousse pousse pousse allez vous
bouffe échec ayrinhac et pouf
voilà qui est maintenant on a deux pions
ça va ça va aller tout seul c'est bon là
ça va puis six à douze secondes et les
cotes sont larges
il voit cette filature sur r quand il
veut ça va aller tanné des makes quid le
ton des pièges de merde c'est chiant
mais il a fait n'importe quoi là encore
et en me faire très attention cfc gagne
encore gagnant selon les coupures à être
bon mais non mais non les échecs de face
mais parfois trop beau non non ça va
faire une du sénat la circulation a lu
sénat très important on n'a même pas
besoin d'aller jusque là les lois de
retour il valait l'idée la matière et là
par exemple il devrait abandonner quand
même mais il fait tourner le tronc
pourquoi pas ouais dit non à ross par
exemple mais c'est par rapport à des
connexions tout à l'heure en face du sa
mère fille puisse regagner par des
connexions donc vu que ça sur caen 3 2
nuls en six nouvelles lignes ou sans
déconner on est à -1 la fab ouais c'est
à dire qu'on est enfin c'est la partie
de décoller enfin si on prend la
déconnexion ne vais pas perdre et le
machin on devrait être à puce a en fait
aller les tontons hashtag kim aronian il
ya des connexions sur le fin mot de
l'histoire de match mais ce serait
dommage
allez les tontons le hashtag le hashtag
lemon le hashtag #civsocial yann dans le
tchat
on est là au monde donne tout partout et
acheté à gages tactile dépôt pour ce
qu'ils n'ont pas on va résister à
laisser le moment de ces loin de jeux
veillées scellement de faire parler les
pouces mais mon l'ipad tout ce bleu la
sueur sur twitch ok minutes vous pour
les ordis partout mais des poux salon id
plus de partout donc
l'alliage 4 dans l'esprit créatif
créatif entre un sale tour à 6 vous
pouvez pas donner des idées à 5
m'expliquer cette tour 17
allait-on 17 non maintenant plf on est
en phase aller on pousse le pion à
chauffer par l'héritier le tournoi c'est
parti harry il arrive je pense qu'il n'a
pas vu tout reprendre cette il n'y
aurait pas laissé sinon il te reprend
pro b 7 ont préféré boubou bon il du bon
côté dark ça c'est là on y peut pas la
perdre et gagner c'est chou n'a pas
beaucoup de temps mais ça devrait aller
cette seconde est tombée me je pense
jouer seul kg 3 on va aussi un peu le
truc pour faire qui approchait 5
je crois que ça marche et je pense aussi
listé pions bon alors je tombais limite
on répète on répète aurait passé coquet
petit peu ramé il faut verser 7 à 5
onces à pousser mais est ce suffisant
non mais peut-être que tafer que nulle
celle là naïma l'otan et c'est très dur
à gagner autant de jouer une autre
[ __ ] mais on est malhonnête et perdre
il menacé
call me soit 6 menace tous
bien joué mon sauvetage c'est beau
allait-on emea skylife cissé fait qu'il
y ait deux fois en menaçant la smat mais
on n'y a plus l'air froid et humide par
contre j'ai trans prenons finales
magnifiques et mannequin malheureusement
moins de nouveau mais je sentais qu'elle
à perdre en fait contre l'essai de la
gagne et indien ouais scène avec g3
quelque part barrette de temps qu'il
fait pas des quatre pour investiguer que
j'ai toujours dit que la bougeotte de
gaz nous plaisir toujours deux points
d'écart train la timone et paula dans le
chat a laissé aller à fond qu'est à 7
c'est l'avantagé de prendre ce truc en a
4 mois parce que s'y fixer quoi
[ __ ] j'y pense ça casse tête mais ça
ne m'inspire pas bondée 6 tessin gagner
un peu toi tu sais pas
est ce que tu penses une position
d'échec ou de rentrer dame chance sans
cesse de rui du turf us à cette nouvelle
majorité en bessin c'est vraiment un
nouveau type de rhuys femmes
ces six lots de qualité dont 106 pas mal
jeu super chaud je sais pas je dis que
des coups comme ça ah oui j'aime bien
c'était complètement débile je pense
fait c'est sympa je sens que tu as de
plus en plus joué dans l'esprit en fait
non mais là on est forcément chaud il
s'est plu à tous
wikileaks est bon en fait on remarque
même pas faire le jeu et clément fromont
c6 peut-être tête ces six noms mais le
français
on se bat et on remet ça donne bimi
trucs pour la colonne des et qu'on
envoie du lourd qui est dit catalan
gigon gigote on sera même tas de paille
de fer h5n1 randonnée
cash 5
non vraiment c'est chaud invoquer la
reprise à disposition il n'y a pas un
fan et blanc refait de l'asb et quatre
idées défendues mais ok y'a pas vraiment
contre jeu d'attaqué contre nos trois
donc tu peux tourner gentiment quoiqu'il
non après moi même c'est que c'est
presque des balles de match à quoi pour
les peaux c'est horrible en fait ce qui
reste plus beaucoup de temps favori
reste une dizaine de minutes
malheureusement c'est ce sera passé vite
en ce soir les quatre heures sans rire
on peut bouger aussi et du dom métro qui
nous fait chier je sais pas ouais c'est
bien cédé 4 devrait succomber tôt ou
tard quand même ça y est on tient les 4
il n'y a plus de courage parce que la
tour est protégée par le pion c6 mais
j'ai fait un bon début mai deux jours
c'est dur à gagner cette phase mais
restons non j statut je peux de mort
contre des touristes
pour cécile mellouki
pour des singles limite c'est sympa est
bien avec ses 8 mai qui gueule tout le
temps quand une soupe
moi je sais c'est le bordel c'est le
bordel dans laquelle peuvent le plus
heureux comme malheureux gadjos tomber
un des six ans non c'est bon là oui mais
voilà c'est qu'il va donner mais ça
c'est pas très sport comme avec aussi
peu de temps sur la pendule machin c'est
pas terrible non il ne ressort pour les
blancs vision alors qu'elle joue ce
qu'il peut nous tous trois coups je
pense ce soir de reprendre son souffle
après pas défini six secondes c'est
beaucoup ouais mais ce qui est bien
c'est que si t'es pas hyper bon à la
souris auquel evans a pas vraiment un
gamer ou quoi c'est hyper pénible quand
tu contraire mais comme naka ou comme
n'importe quoi qui sont des mecs qui
font moins sept nuls qui bouge vite cv
ni ne s'était jamais sûr on revient à un
point
allez pour la gagner cela allait aux
cases c4 gambie chinois non j'ai quatre
s'appelle choix je me dis encore mais
moi aussi jouer ça c'est mes dix mois en
fait je pense à peu près le même
répertoire bien je suis plutôt gambie
staunton aux quatre fantastiques le
message de reaper et dressera 18 chats
tu n'es pas il fait pas le beau jeu même
d'un cas qui est un connard est plus
forte mais qui sont choquants sur le
tchat
je viens de terminer sa main peu de
folie ou non ses échecs ben moi j'aime
bien epona cas et sous quelque part
c'est face c'est cool illustration en
anglais we love to haiti mme on aime le
détester en fait mal ça va je pense look
et maintenant hashcash de tour des
boîtes y aller il faut revenir en tout
cas faut pas la perdre des fonds pour la
megadrive et ça je pense oui claude
bessy de tous
elle ça je pense pas mauvais c'est chaud
un benzema changeux fc 4 par l oms les
ciseaux prochain l'armée n'a pas trouvé
si cela est si je vois sur fou prend
d'un prêt mais ça doit aller j'allais
dire dam des trois meilleurs atouts
français cissé on va les mater en force
le roi noir quand même un peu faible
ouais ouais
d'abord note alger 6 h 600 têtes tout le
vol allez on va d'amour âge sombre où
ils peuvent seulement d'un magicien de
rage cette attention
ouais bon goût vous vous des saints sean
payton je pense si les catalans ont
donné juste page 2 dont le 4 août
j'ai trouvé le tour c'est six allers
retours c'est si simple à la 10e' fait
défaut d'un mois laurent verger kata les
rois et froid prochain e3 pas je sais
pas je sais pas j'aime bien j'aime je
les blancs
ils font pas mal le jour a changé 5 g 5
années boum
le roi répond j'y tiendrai séquence six
tours à charles et tourache un tour non
je sais pas chanter elle est sûre apple
a essuyé en fait elle est tantôt deux
maquillés 3,6 mais il a plus de temps il
a plus de temps ça me ça me stresse moi
j'en peux plus gens me faisaient
cavalier installé je suis pas batwa qui
a eu huit échecs face à catane et monte
sa pelouse 3 5 13.14 en revue fort ah
oui la fourchette au hc peur qu'ils
aient peur qu'il peut à 7 en trois jeux
3d il ya trois secondes
c'est au bout maintenant tombeau de
trois secondes mes propres presse à part
a ajouté une seconde là ça lui rajoute
plus de temps ça lui rajoute pas de ton
jeu qu'on va ça rajoute pas de temps
c'est pas la bonne cadence de nom mais
regarde ça rejetant mediapad ya pas de
rage ou ya pas de rage ou c'est pas
légal alors s'il y aura je ne sais pas
pourquoi ça rajoute évasion sery bally
toujours en vie s'est passé c'est un bug
d'affichage probablement mais bon je
veux placer c'est comme quand tu regarde
pas le foot à la télé il n'y a pas de
drame orbital qui sera alors arrête
c'est la mauvaise cadence
certes il assure qu' à leur âge où on
peut se plaindre si on veut se plaindre
comme on regarde du foot être de bonne
foi c'est très beau mais quand on
regarde du sport les commentateurs sur
tf1 aussi on va venir après tu comptes
comme comme namsa savons même pas comme
ça mais si on regarde le foot sur tf1
tu l'as toujours penalty face à va il
fait le ballon de la main sans aller
d'un match 4 aura lieu saint cloud pour
h3 allez je sais pas dans l'esprit j'en
peux plus aller damage quatre cailloux 6
tfk attal et allez allez allez on y va
il reste combien il reste trois minutes
voire faible j'en peux plus favoris au
bout quoi se dote d'un parti non après
ouais pas les heures mais j'en veux plus
femme
j'en veux plus c'est horrible je
n'arrive même pas regardé la femme
imaginée imagine que si on à mpm dans
une situation pareille mais ça va être
horrible donne de si non c'est de la
merde
ces cinq coups j'en peux plus faibles
j'en peux plus je n'en peux plus son
pion faut aussi possible un peuple c'est
comme en souffrance dont je parle bien
du tout quoi bon jour pour faire mieux
on attend demain c'est horrible c'est
horrible on peut plus gagner et tout et
on réfléchit le reste plus que 20
secondes on va la perdre fab on en train
de perdre ce match
ok dessin commencé qu il un peu fou cran
de ge
il est découverte l'avocat comprends
j'ai décidé qu on fait d'un mètre
froides à france 3 où le match amelia
cavaliers 3 [ __ ] tampon ou trois bons
noms à putte
j'en peux plus je n'en peux plus on est
mal autant lte il attaque avec son
cavalier j'en ai marre qui est riche et
cissé sur dame est sûre d'un match 6
dames b2c de 9,6 problème c'est que 3000
de 20 et que ça soit une passante
derrière bart de wever c'est la swatch
est une île et puis on allait on se bat
sur 960 voilà open mais en fait je suis
pas sûr a réussi à retenir c'est la
femme et de cinq secondes au lieu d'un
exploit tenir celle là dit elle le
public a tout sous la halle et n'est
plus le roi se casse çà les mains comme
un balai ou la torah ce lundi où là il a
vu il a vu aronian à les bouges 8 non il
est tombé
bref vous gagnez vous en faire 2 sur 2 à
la france est allée les bonnes aïcha
devant castres bombe
non mais c'est pas si mal aux reds
j'avais un peu à réaliser pour la pub
rock mais c'est débile une bonne ni en
fait ni pau c'est une reconversion dans
un livre j'ai vu ça et le fait qu'ils
disent je sais plus si c'est berg qui
recommande ça ou ou à garde mes années
deux pas je pense seibert qui recommande
de jeu comme ça qui a fait un gros
travail sur france 3 qui fait trois gros
livre mais je vois femmes et la savane à
lhassa jus dans la tête famille si on
est là mais la mauvaise position peut la
gagner femmes
je te 103 au ps le parti ait lieu très
bientôt tomber un peu tranquille
n'oubliez pas tous les matches avec les
verts que tu as pu suivre était très
souffrant fait elle reste en fait ça
c'est chiant ça qui nous joue vite ou
tombent y bouge tombions des trois
contre un qui ont des cannes design je
pas compris hcc en fait j'ai pas compris
de quoi ce système
david a poussé ses pions en l2 contre
caen nantes a crié qu'il est bon que tu
vas faire de menaces alors vous êtes psa
perd on sait tout bouffer [ __ ] ça va
changer d'âme pour voir quoi elle tous
les sketchs en h1 la donne a changé
package pas où la pierre kast et deux en
train de perdre ce match mais bon c'est
bon mais juste ok c'est quand même
désagréables cette histoire de deux
pénalités
ça change beaucoup de choses je proviens
comme un débile ou alors tu veux juste
jouer et si tu fais nul ça va toujours
vivant ça change beaucoup de choses de
quoi presque aller en europe ou être ici
à 3,17 à tanguer une pièce n'est pas
revivre un peu en caisse depuis ça vous
voyez si je vais vous parler de plus
c'est quand même quelque chose que cette
fois ci
et trois infirmiers autant qu'on sait si
ce passionné de merde j'aurais bien
faire un tour prend à d'autant qu'on
sait si ce vote comme samou moi j 3
monte à la volée et monte à la volée
qu'il monte à la volée 3 ou là là là
j'aime pas ce roi faible la [ __ ] cette
grande dame gk on va être obligé cédric
fabre ou wiki formation à trois et dams
dam des trois échecs échec autres pour
detroit
non mais problème c'est qu'il est trop
rapide avec la souris en fait ok c'est
ça le problème est tombé c'est juste que
je dis quoi bah c'est fini non mais
c'est horrible
il n'est pas assez rapide à la souris en
fait c'est souvent fait file à mieux
jouer mais ok il se prend deux pénalités
il perd une partition des faillites pour
une partie des connexions machin et il
est mon rapide à la souris c'est tout
autre chose
entre joie et notamment aux échecs et
qu'une souris alors mais c'est c'est la
souris kayani en fait il a gagné la
souris c'est horrible mais bon la
veillée en pré-match lorenzo moi c'était
mon pronostic en plateau final mais
validé son goût amer non mais j'aime pas
trop le fait de le jeu à la souris pas
dans le sens d un parti n'a pas gagné
parce que factuelles vraiment essayé de
le flag est en fait autour de moi naka
il fait un peu ça aussi mais peut-être
un peu moins dans les speechs s qui veut
pas avoir une très mauvaise image et
crade
c'était quand même assez crade il a
quand même essayé assez souvent de flag
et ou de faire ça il a essayé de trouver
des trucs entre crade mais bon ces jeux
aussi un pain aux pauvres du set où cela
il est bien et vous voyez plus dangereux
qu on a beaucoup de mal à s'enflammer
quoi mais bon du beau jeu 3-2 quoi nous
rendre sa tâche c'est pas du tout ça
marche c'est quand même mon fils
bon ok tant son 17e match est fini entre
nous on s'en fout il se fait plaisir
il lâche ses coups ouais c'est dommage
grave ça laissera un goût amer
ce sera un goût amer ben non mais c'est
cette pénalité et fichiers ou l'autre le
flag âge pas mon mec éminemment il ya
deux points de plus en a partout et
déconnecté il tombe alors qu'il ya deux
secondes et il a de plus en plus à un
deuil aucune raison et puis déconnecter
en humaine imparfaite dans la tronche le
parti d'après ça fait lourd quoi
changement ou autre chose
la revue c'est assez dommage j'aurais
gagné la précédente se faire flinguer
blade bêtement veille jeu pour revenir
et le losc pasqua compte il ya match nul
dans un speech ça va en fait sans la
pénalité y aurait égalité et qui se
défient abbas a continué à jouer je
crois qu'il joue 1,5 plus de 1,3 plus un
plus un du coup après mon mais c'est
dommage qu'il ya deux points d'écart en
fait c'est la déconnexion le point
d'écart enfin ça aurait pu faire un
match nul mythique en fait au caire est
un gros match est terminé quoi donc
victoire de données pour 15 à 13
non ma mérité quand même hein il aura
bien joué il aura bien défendu il aura
trouvé un bien mené bien bouger les
pièces y aura bien un jour avec sa
souris c'est dommage c'est pas gai la
précédente et gagner celle-là comme ça
pour égaliser
on sent qu'il en paie à l'aise quand
même aronian c'est la deuxième année
consécutive qui se fait éliminer comme
ça de justesse pas très heureux que tu
ne viennent pas chat noir disait mvl
pour pour le match je pense qu'elle
verrait très heureux qu'une commande pas
son âge son match
une sacrée énergie contesté gonzaga kg
d'or 18 a commenté enfin j'attends
cancan guichou s'est qualifié contre
contre aronian basse était malade et
j'ai quand même commandé guadeloupe qui
est passé contrat porte notamment
intégré choc est passée contre appart
bon ça va c'est pas ça va c'est pas méga
chat noir mais était quand même cher
gris foncé oui on sait je suis peuvent
mettre le plus de chances au monde quoi
tout le pain de mrdja rideau à tempe et
alès lens ouvre mais on se connaît
non mais t'es regarder le beach s il
s'est vu j'ai entendu parler de ce
connard là fabien liebowitz en réunion
celle émise est si bon voyons se
trouvait sur le nom et simon juragai
fitch est pour moi et là il s'est dit
oui bon le mec à une déconnexion il a
perdu une partie pénalisé c'est un
connard fini c'était vraiment le chat
noir
après il a regardé les saint-etienne
après la naissance de fabien le palmarès
mumbai retrouve plus exc c'est quand
même le connard de base et le mec vient
voir à new york et apparemment il serait
en train de feindre une blessure si tu
veux faire dans une élection il ne veut
pas d'un fin aux fidèles de montréal
qu'aux niveaux pour être crédible oui
c'est ça déjà qu'on a pris les billets
d'avion il a dit amir cas je vais jouer
montréal le masters 1000 avant parce que
l us open t'oublie quoi tu as dit il
arrive alors le prochain speech à ce
sera jeudi 31 août avec maxime vachier
lagrave
allez les bleus contre les frictions et
là vous n'avez pas intérêt à nous mettre
des pénalités sur maxime parce que là je
rentre sur le direction de trucs en
village des vieux port voilà je les
emmerde la luronne sur le sujet rien à
[ __ ] alors on va dire juste ou non non
les défonçage arrivée lots daniel wrench
à l'aide ait pas de grille penalty forte
us dot com comme boum
du coup on brûle les vaillons direct
barca est ou non et même dans 10 ans on
en parle encore enfin on fait des scream
tous les jeudis on fait des stream
pour en parler tout en assurant c'est
quand même bien amusant a passé une très
bonne soirée en votre compagnie je passe
souvent y penser on peut il parler de
deux minutes avec
mais le coach us avec le soin seraient
parents qui m'ont ri sachez qu'ils
aiment faire l'interview elle note sauce
mousseline aux lianes you will be cause
d'un feu de penalty
what do you want me to do quoi allez
vous rendre fou de guy bach de games
quoi enfin ils auraient quand même pu
rendre la partie
franchement non non mais ça ne s'était
pas chez paraissent de parents la partie
je sais pas assez je passe comme si tu
as marqué alors que qui avait un joueur
qui était par terre machin très bienvenu
mais ok donc demain vous à notre match
speech on commentera pas parce que ça va
être vraiment la nuit entre midi et
trois heures midi minuit et 3 heures du
mat
cela dit pour les insomniaques
travaillent la nuit ou poussés par la
faim vous voulez j'ai montré ce soir et
vous pouvez vous connecter une sera
contée en anglais 300 adhésions à les
commentateurs est ce que a
et du coup c'est honnête ça peut marcher
et moi je vais demain je vais avec le
clash royal comme un malade quoi bébés
dragons dont tagada dégage mais des
réponses qui vient il serait le match à
côté quoi et mais quoi d'autre mais
demandé jeudi le live en fait ah oui au
val d'aran dacic
n'oubliez pas encore mais on est
toujours là on est tu t'en heureux live
à 20 heures je sais pas ce qu'on fait
c'est quoi demain tournoi de remonter en
bullet fait chier chaud là bas je sais
pas on verra demain comment je suis
choquée mais en fait je suis entré
contre falla le match va pas fatigué le
match mais plutôt tu vois une bonne
humeur ouais je suis de bonne humeur
je suis très bonne humeur et ce match
m'a beaucoup plu c'est très excitant
ils sont en train de parler à sa mère
j'ai envie de venir et 9,2 parle aussi
en fait les rails dont tony voiture je
ne suis pas d'accord
on lira le compte rendu chez ce point
comme en fait on va écrire un compte
rendu à nous en fait ouais levon aronian
très mécontents on le voit d'ailleurs en
fin de set genre images de sa karma
prego rhmani s'est déplacé à moscou vous
fait c'est là qu'elle est à bertrand 90
je pense qu aronian l'aurait rendu bout
c'est qui je serai là à demain du coup
il est très content d'être avec 98 non
mais j'espère qu'on va trouver le
sommeil après ce match
non mais après midi parce que leur est
il des 12-17 ans attends je mets un
jameer les master classes je me fais
plaisir
ah bah oui des master class bon vous en
parle dans master class maroc tout ça au
cv ou le dis quand même donc demain
c'est quoi ces facteurs maintenant 21h30
on va vers 21h30 bon je suis pas ce
qu'on fera le g10 bullet mais je sais
pas vraiment encore faim mais aussi le
petit live ici même donc pareil sous les
partager on semble qu'on rigole un peu
et puis
puis voilà quoi donc purgé un match
speech est ce moi je serais pas là dans
huit jours
mais une telle idrac m on commande pour
maxime donc et et puis voilà prêt en
septembre felli ont fait les lettres du
monde 0 30 familles ou deux par année
séjour aux états unis je peux revenir
dessus quad fine bouche de nos jours la
chaîne vous souhaite à tous une
excellente soirée
goodbye tiens